GOVERNMENT HEARING CALLING FOR
MEMBERS THIS IS THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE IN ROOM
FOUR FOUR SEVEN SERGEANTS SPEAKS
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS -- DO A
FEW HOUSEKEEPING RULES FOR THIS
AFTERNOON WE HAVE TEN ITEMS ON
THE AGENDA TODAY TWO ITEMS ARE
PROPOSED FOR CONSENT.
ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB TEN NINETY
FIVE EDUARDO GARCIA.
ITEM NUMBER TEN AB EIGHTEEN
TWENTY TWO COMMITTEE ON LOCAL
GOVERNMENT.
WILL ENTERTAIN A MOTION ON
CONSENT ONCE WE HAVE A QUORUM
STAB WISHED AND WE HEAR BILLS IN
THIS COMMITTEE -- IN SIGN IN
ORDER OUR FIRST BILL TODAY WILL
BE ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB TEN FIFTY
THREE ASSEMBLYMEMBER DOLLY.
I WILL BE STARTING AS A SUB
COMMITTEE TODAY.
I KNOW YOU'RE IN A SHOT THIS IS
WE WORK THIS INVESTMENT GOOD.
YOU'RE TALKING LANGUAGE.
WELL MY MISTER ASSEMBLYMEMBER.
WARNING MEMBERS I KNOW THAT THIS
BILL ENJOYS -- SUPPORT SUPPORTS
ALL BE SOMEWHAT BRIEF.
TODAY PRESIDING A. B. TEN FIFTY
THREE WHICH RELATES THE FALLEN
LEAF LAKE IN TAHOE LAKE TAHOE
AREA THE BILL'S EXPERT --
EXPRESSES THE INTENT OF THE
LEGISLATURE TO ADDRESS
RECOMMENDATIONS IN THE
CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITOR'S AUDIT.
OF THE FALLEN LEAF LAKE
COMMUNITY SERVICE DISTRICT.
AS REQUESTED BY THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE AUDIT J. LACK IN
AUGUST TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN THE
AUDIT WAS ORIGINALLY REQUESTED
IN AMENDMENTS TO SB FIVE SIXTY
ONES WHICH WAS A GAINES AND HILL
BILL IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN BY
THE ASSEMBLY LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COMMITTEE.
AND THE BILL WAS SUBSEQUENTLY
HELD.
IN THE ASSEMBLY AFTER THE J.
LACK APPROVE THE AUDIT.
SB FIVE SIXTY ONE CREATED A
HYBRID LANDOWNER REGISTERED
VOTER ELECTORAL PROCESS FOR THE
DISTRICT BECAUSE THERE ARE SO
FEW PEOPLE LIVING IN THE
DISTRICT TO QUALIFY AS VOTERS.
AND ARE ELIGIBLE TO SERVE.
ON THE DISTRICT BOARD OF
DIRECTORS THE ISSUE RAISED BY
THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE BECAME
THE BASIS OF THE AUDIT AND WILL
BE SUBJECT TO FUTURE MEMBERS TO
THIS BILL WHEN THE AUDIT IS
ACTUALLY COMPLETE EARLIER THIS
YEAR THE BILL'S OPERATIVE
SECTION.
ALSO RESTRICTS THE PROVISION OF
THE SERVICE BY THE DISTRICT.
FIRE PROTECTION INCLUDING
MEDICAL RESPONSE AND EMERGENCY
SERVICES AND PARK AND RECREATION
SERVICES AT RICHARD HARRIS HERE.
WHO COULD ANSWER THE TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE?
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- MADAM
CHAIR FOR THE FIRST TIME IN MY
LIFE I'M JUST SOME PLACE TO BE
ABLE TO ANSWER TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS -- JUST DOESN'T SEEM
RIGHT BUT I AM I'M HERE THAT
SAID ONE SUPPORT.
FROM THE NORSEMAN FROM WE
REPRESENT THIS DISTRICT WE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP.
THE THE ON IT I THINK IS GOING
TO TURN OUT TO BE A REAL GOOD
IDEA WHICH IS WHAT YOU TOLD ME
LAST YEAR SO LET'S ANSWER SOME
QUESTIONS AND WE DON'T KNOW WHAT
IT'S GOING TO SAY BUT IT
CERTAINLY WILL PROVIDE AS A
BASIS TO MOVE FORWARD AND WE
LOOK.
FORWARD TO THEM GET KNOCKED DOWN
AND WE MOVE FORWARD WITH THIS
THIS BILL RIGHT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH IS THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
HEALTHWISE BUT THE DISTRICT SAYS
HE SAID -- WE'VE BEEN WORKING
WITH PUBLICLY.
WE FOLLOWING THIS THIS ISSUE WE
LOOK FORWARD TO THE AUDIT COMING
OUT -- AND WORKING WITH THE
DISTRICT AND THE LEGISLATURE ON
RESOLVING ANY ISSUES FOLLOWING
THE AUDIT.
GREAT THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
SAYING THAT ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN A IN OPPOSITION.
AGAIN THING THERE ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE.
YES.
MADAM CHAIR OF TWENTY ONE SHORT
QUESTIONS.
JUST KIDDING.
SO HE SUBTRACTED TWENTY OF THEM --
RULE LET'S SEE -- WE WILL
ENTERTAIN A MOTION ONCE WE GET A
OUR COMMITTEE HERE AND WE'LL GET
BACK TO YOU AND WHAT FORGET IT
WAS WORTH IT.
SO -- DO YOU HAVE ANY CLOSING
YES I JUST LIKE TO SAY THIS IS A
DISTRICT BILL -- WE'RE JUST
TRYING TO SUPPLY FIRE SERVICES
MEDICAL SERVICE FOR AN AREA THAT
HAS A LOT OF OWNERS WHO DON'T
LIVE THERE SO THAT'S OUR GOAL IS
TO ACTUALLY PROVIDE SERVICES FOR
PEOPLE WHO NEED THEM.
RIGHT SO THE PROJECT AND I DON'T
WITH THANKS VERY MUCH AND I AM
LOOKING FORWARD TO HEARING
WITHOUT COMES OUT AND YOU'RE
TAKING THOSE MINUTES THANK YOU
MATTER MEMBERS.
ALL RIGHT WE HAVE ITEM NUMBER
TWO TODAY'S ITEM NINE AB
SEVENTEEN THIRTY GONZALEZ NO
SHE'S NOT HERE WELL I THINK
WE'LL TAKE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GLORIA WOULD YOU LIKE TO SPEAK.
AB.
FOURTEEN THIRTEEN AND HIS ITEM
NUMBER.
EIGHT DON'T BE SCARED YOU CAN
SIT DOWN. TWENTY SURE HAVE
ACCRUED MADAM CHAIR.
RIGHT AND THEY'RE VALUABLE JAMES.
THE BACKUP DANCERS I KNOW.
STANDARD EQUIPMENT -- OKAY GOOD
MOVE GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT AB --
FOURTEEN THIRTEEN THIS AFTERNOON --
MEMBERS I THINK YOU KNOW HOW
DIVERSE OUR STATE IS AND WE
OFTEN HEAR ABOUT THE UNIQUE AND
VERY NEEDS A VARIOUS PARTS THE
STATE NORTHERN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA CLOSER INLAND
COMMUNITIES -- FOR THOSE OF US
THAT COME FROM LOCAL GOVERNMENT
WE KNOW THAT THESE DIFFERENCES
EXIST EVEN WITHIN SMALLER
JURISDICTIONS THAT WE REPRESENT
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT COMES TO
ISSUES OF TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE -- AS LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS PLAN FOR
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
IMPROVEMENTS PROGRESS I THINK
ALL OF US TO SEE COULD BE
STYMIED.
WITH THE NEEDS OF ONE COMMUNITY
MAY DIFFER FROM THAT OF
NEIGHBORING LOCAL COMMUNITY.
UNFORTUNATELY NEITHER SIDE
REGION REALIZE ANY BENEFIT AND
THE CITY AND THE SAME FEELING
INFRASTRUCTURE WHETHER BE
TRANSIT ROAD REPAIR GO WITHOUT
IMPROVEMENTS FOR DECADES.
AB FOURTEEN THIRTEEN SEEKS TO
CHANGE THAT BY ALLOWING LOCAL
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITIES THAT
HAVE THE ABILITY TO ADVANCE
IMPROVEMENT PROJECTS BY
SUBREGION SUBREGIONS HAVE SHOWN
A DESIRE TO GET PAST THE
POLITICAL GRIDLOCK IN AN EFFORT
TO MAKE IMPROVEMENTS TO THEIR
COMMUNITIES.
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN AND TWENTY
EIGHTEEN SEVERAL TRANSPORTATION
MEASURES APPEARED ON BALLOTS
ACROSS THE STATE IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN SIX PASSED IN EIGHT
FAILED.
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN THREE PASSED
INTO FIELD HOWEVER AND THOSE
THAT FAILED WE SELL CLEAR
EVIDENCE THAT QUARTERS A
CONSTITUENCIES TO SUPPORT THE
MEASURE. FOR EXAMPLE IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN TRANSPORTATION FUNDING
MEASURES IN CONTRA COSTA COUNTY
IN PLASTER COUNTY CAME WITHIN
PERCENTAGE POINTS OF MEETING THE
66% THRESHOLD NEEDED FOR TAX
INCREASE DESPITE LARGE
CONCENTRATIONS OF SUPPORT.
THIS BILL I WANT TO BE CLEAR
DOES NOT CHANGE THE VOTER
APPROVAL THRESHOLD THAT SOMEONE
ELSE'S BILL -- HUNDRED THIS BILL
HOWEVER IF OF FUNDING MEASURES
APPROVED BY THE REQUIRED NUMBER
VOTERS COMMUNITIES WOULD BE
INSURED INSURED THAT THE
DECISION TO TAX THEMSELVES WOULD
NOT BE IN VAIN.
AS THE REVENUES GENERATED FROM
THE SALES TAX WOULD BE AVAILABLE
TO THE COMMUNITIES THAT SOUGHT
IT.
WITH ME THIS AFTERNOON OUR
REPRESENTATIVES FROM CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE FOR JOBS -- AS WELL AS
PLASTER COUNTY -- AND I WILL
TURN IT OVER THEM IF THAT'S
PLEASES THE CHAIR IF YOU WOULD
JUST GIVE ME A SECOND SINCE WE
HAVE A QUORUM -- YEAH WE'D LIKE
TO DO A ROLL CALL AND SO WE CAN
MOVE ON TODAY SO I WILL BE RIGHT
WITH YOU THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE.
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY HERE
LACKEY BLOOM.
BLOOM HAIR BURNER HARD FAST.
RAMOS THREE OF US.
THREE OF US HERE ROBERT RIVAS
ROBERT RIVAS HERE VOEPEL.
VOEPEL HERE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE HAVE A
QUORUM WILL -- YOU CAN CONTINUE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR -- MY NAME
IS JIM ARE -- I'M HERE AT THE
REQUEST OF PLASTER COUNTY.
I IT'S A PLEASURE TO BE HERE I
HAVEN'T BEEN MY THIS MICROPHONE
FEW YEARS SINCE I RETIRED SO --
I GUESS IS KINDA LIKE RIDING A
BIKE WILL FIND OUT -- I DO LIKE
THE WAY YOU RUN A MEETING THOUGH
HAVING AND FORMER CHAIR OF A THE
CALIFORNIA TRANSFER
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION -- I
LIKE THE WAY YOU RUN A MEETING
SO FAR GOOD JOB HELPS IS I DO
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THAT'S NICE THE BILL.
THIS BY WAY OF BRIEF
INTRODUCTION -- ACTUALLY I AM NO
LONGER -- IT'S IT'S IT'S I AM
RETIRED I I CAN'T SAY I
REPRESENT THE CALIFORNIA WINES
FOR JOBS DIRECTLY ANYMORE BUT
THEY ARE CERTAINLY IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL.
AND I I SERVE THERE IS THERE
CHIEF EXECUTIVE OFFICER FOR
EIGHTEEN YEARS -- AND IT
REPRESENTS MORE THAN FIFTY
THOUSAND LABOR'S HEAVY EQUIPMENT
OPERATORS AND CARPENTERS.
AND FIFTEEN HUNDRED CONTRACTORS.
THAT BILL MOST OF THE ROADS AND
BRIDGES AND OTHER INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT CALIFORNIANS RELY ON EVERY
DAY.
I ALSO SERVED FOR TWELVE YEARS --
AS A GROUP TO TOUR A
GUBERNATORIAL APPOINTEE FOR TO
GOVERNOR'S ON THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION.
LASTLY -- I'M A TWENTY YEAR
RESIDENT PLASTER COUNTY WHICH IS
ONE OF A NUMBER OF COUNTIES IN
THE STATE THAT WOULD BENEFIT
GREATLY FROM THE PROVISIONS OF
AB.
FOURTEEN THIRTEEN A MOST IN THIS
ROOM ARE FAMILIAR.
WITH ONE OF THE TOOLS AVAILABLE
TO COUNTIES IN THE CALIFORNIA
THAT PROVIDES THEM AUTHORITY TO
SEE VOTER APPROVAL FOR A COUNTY
WIDE SALES TAX FUND TO TRANSPORT --
FUND TO FUND TRANSPORTATION
PROJECTS.
THERE ARE CRITICALLY NEEDED BUT
LACKS SUFFICIENT FUNDING.
THESE DEDICATED SALES TAXES
REQUIRE TWO THIRDS VOTER
APPROVAL AND IN MOST CASES ARE
NOT EASY TO PASS THEY HAVE TO BE
GOOD MEASURES.
SUCCESSFUL TRANSPORTATION SALES
TAX MEASURES REQUIRE A CAREFULLY
DEVELOPED EXPENDITURE PLAN AND
THAT IS THE PRODUCT OF COUNTLESS
HOURS OF PUBLIC OUTREACH AND
INPUT.
AND ALMOST WITHOUT EXCEPTION
CONSIST OF A THOUGHTFUL BALANCE
OF CAPITAL PROJECTS PUBLIC
TRANSIT IMPROVEMENTS SAFE ROUTES
TO SCHOOLS.
PROGRAMS AND PROJECTS DESIGNED
TO RELIEVE TRAFFIC CONGESTION
AND ENCOURAGE PEOPLE TO REDUCE
THE RELIANCE ON AUTOMOBILES.
THERE ARE CURRENTLY TWENTY SIX
OF WHAT WE CALL SELF HELP
COUNTIES THROUGHOUT THE STATE
THAT HAVE SUCCESSFULLY PASSED IN
IMPLEMENTED ONE OR MORE OF THESE
MEASURES OVER THE YEARS.
AS ONE WHO DEVOTED A SIGNIFICANT
SIGNIFICANT CHUNK OF MY CAREER
HELPING COUNTIES TO DEVELOP
THESE PLANS AND CRAFT EDUCATION
CAMP CAMPAIGNS -- SEEKING VOTER
APPROVAL FOR THESE MEASURES.
IT WAS VERY GRATIFYING TO HAVE A
PART IN HELPING PASSED OF THESE
MEASURES AND THEN SEE HOW WELL
MOST COUNTIES PUT THOSE FUNDS TO
WORK. FOR THE BETTERMENT OF THE
LOCAL RESIDENTS THE TAXPAYERS
THE ECONOMY AND THE ENVIRONMENT.
ON THE FLIP SIDE I CAN ALSO
RELATE TO MANY SAID EXPERIENCES
OF COUNTIES THAT HAVE LITERALLY
EXHAUSTED THEMSELVES IN REPEATED
EFFORTS TO SEEK VOTER APPROVAL.
FOR CRITICALLY NEEDED
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
BUT BECAUSE OF THE DIVERSITY
GEOGRAPHY AND DEMOGRAPHICS OF
THE COUNTY -- HAVE NEVER BEEN
ABLE TO ACHIEVE THAT SELF HELP
COUNTY STATUS -- A. B. FOURTEEN
THIRTEEN WOULD GIVE SUCH
COUNTIES AN ADDITIONAL TOOL THAT
COULD HELP THEM ADDRESS SOME OF
THEIR MOST CRITICAL
TRANSPORTATION NEEDS.
THIS BILL AUTHORIZES SPECIFIED
LOCAL TRANSPORTATION AGENCIES
THAT HAVE EXISTING TRANSFER
TRANSACTION AND USE TAX
AUTHORITY. TO LEVY A
TRANSACTIONS AND USE TAX -- IN
ANY PORTION OF US JURISDICTION.
WITH TWO THIRDS VOTER APPROVAL
IT'S NOT A TAX BILL IT JUST
GIVES OF THEM THIS TOOL TO BE
ABLE. TO SEEK A DIFFERENT SUBSET
OF COUNTY MEMBERS TO BE ABLE TO
VOTE ON A NEEDED INFRASTRUCTURE.
AB FOURTEEN THIRTEEN WOULD ALSO
REQUIRE THAT THE LOCAL
TRANSPORTATION AGENCY IDENTIFIED
THE PORTION OF ITS JURISDICTION.
IN WHICH THE TAX WOULD APPLY
PRIOR TO REPRESENTING THE
PROPOSAL TO THE VOTERS FOR
APPROVAL.
ADDITIONALLY THIS BILL REQUIRES
THAT REVENUES MUST ONLY BE USED
IN THE AREA OF THE COUNTY WHERE
THE TAX APPLIES.
PLASTER COUNTY WHERE I LIVE IS A
POSTER CHILD FOR WHY A. B.
FOURTEEN THIRTEEN IS NEEDED OUR
COUNTY IS A LONG STRIP OF LAND
THAT RUNS FROM THE FLATLANDS OF
LINCOLN IN ROSEVILLE UP THE FOOT
HILLS THROUGH AUBURN COLFAX IN
EAST TOWARD ALL THE WAY TO LAKE
TAHOE.
AND THE NEVADA BORDER A RECENT
EFFORT TO APPROVE A
TRANSPORTATION EXPENDITURE PLAN
THEIR FAILED BY ONLY 2% WHEN YOU
CONSIDER THAT A CONSERVATIVE
VOTER A PROFILE OF PLASTER
COUNTY.
THAT TELLS YOU SOMETHING THERE
WERE A LOT OF VOTERS THAT REALLY
WANTED TO FIX SOME PROBLEMS AND
THEY CAME UP JUST.
SHORT OF BEING ABLE TO DO IT.
BUT WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE BUT BUT
SO WHAT YOU SEE AN IN PLASTER
COUNTY -- THE POSSIBILITIES THAT
THAT THEY COULD USE THIS BILL.
FOR TO HELP THEM -- TO CRAFT A
MEASURE THAT REALLY WOULD GET
THE MOST SIGNIFICANT SIGNIFICANT --
INFRASTRUCTURE DONE -- IS -- IT
IS WHY WE WERE IN SUPPORT OF
THAT MEASURE -- IS THE WESTERN
PART OF PLASTER COUNTY WHICH
CONTAINS THE VAST MAJORITY OF
THE POPULATION -- AND AND THE
MOST CONGESTION IN THE GREATEST
NEED FOR TRANSPORTATION
IMPROVEMENTS WHEN I MOVED THERE --
TWENTY YEARS AGO HIGHWAY --
SIXTY FIVE WAS NEWLY BUILT IT
WAS A NICE PIECE OF ROAD THAT --
I KIND OF WONDERED AT THE TIME.
WHY WAS THERE BECAUSE THERE WAS
NOT MUCH AROUND IT YOU COULD
ROLL BOWLING BALL ABOUT ROAD
NEVER HAD A THING?
THAT IS NOT THE CASE TODAY IN
FACT JUST A FEW WEEKS AGO --
CALTRANS -- INSTITUTED A
METERING PROGRAM THAT GOES FROM
SIX AM TO SIX PM EVERY DAY AND
INCLUDING SOME -- MOST OF THE
DAY ON SATURDAYS AND SUNDAYS
THERE ARE VERY FEW PLACES IN ALL
OF CALIFORNIA INCLUDING LA AND
IN THE BAY AREA THAT HAVE THAT
KIND OF METERING PROGRAM.
SO YOU CAN SEE THEY HAVE SOME
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS AND THIS
BILL WOULD BE IT WOULD GIVE THEM
THE OPPORTUNITY TO TO CARVE OUT
AN AREA WHERE THE CITIZENS WOULD
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY. TO VOTE ARE
PROJECTS THAT THEY RECOGNIZE AND
AND THAT THEY NEED AND DECIDE
WHETHER OR NOT THEY WANT TO DIG
IN THEIR POCKET -- SO. FOR THOSE
REASONS -- I WOULD RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE ON THIS
BILL THANK YOU THANKS VERY MUCH.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MY NAME IS
MIKE LUCAN ON THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE PLASTER COUNTY
TRANSPORTATION PLANNING AGENCY --
WE REPRESENT OUR ELECTED BOARD
OF CITIES AND COUNTIES IN
PLASTER COUNTY AND ALSO ARE A
VITAL MEMBER OF THE SACRAMENTO
AREA COUNCIL GOVERNMENTS WHO IS
ALSO A LARGE SUPPORTER OF THIS
BILL.
I'M ALSO HERE IS TODAY AS A
SPOKESPERSON FOR A COALITION OF
ADVOCATES WHO BELIEVE AB
FOURTEEN THIRTEEN CAN BE ARE
AFFECTED NEW TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE TOOL.
AND WE ARE VERY ENTHUSIASTIC
ABOUT IT BY IT BEING ABLE TO
ENABLE SUB REGIONS TO CHOOSE
WHETHER THEY WANT TO TAX
THEMSELVES HAVING THE ASSURANCE
THAT THESE TAXES WILL GO BACK TO
THEIR COMMUNITY.
WE BELIEVE THE BILL WILL EMPOWER
WHAT WE TERM AS COMMUNITIES
COMMON INTEREST -- WITHIN OUR
COUNTY TO BE ABLE. TO TO BECOME
ABLE PARTNERS WITH THE STATE TO
DELIVER THE TRANSPORTATION
SYSTEMS WE NEED FOR OUR STATE
THAT IS GROWING VERY QUICKLY.
AND WE NEED IN OUR STATES.
ALL THE RESOURCES OF OUR STATE
IN THE PLASTER COUNTY AND OTHER
AREAS TO IMPROVE THE ENVIRONMENT
AND TO IMPROVE THE COMMUNITY.
OUR COALITION IS BASED IN
PLASTER COUNTY IS MADE UP OF OF
OF A BROAD BASED GROUP MADE UP
OF LABOR GROUPS.
CHAMBERS OF COMMERCE HOUSING
ADVOCATES CIVIL ENGINEERS
BUSINESSPERSONS AIR QUALITY
PROPONENTS OF PLANNERS WE ARE
ALSO JOINED IN SUPPORT BY THE
NORTH STATE BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION LABORS LOCAL.
ONE EIGHTY FIVE THE ROCKLIN ROSE
WILL IN LINCOLN CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE THE CITY OF LINCOLN
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT COUNCIL.
THE MAYOR OF THE CITY OF
ROSEVILLE THE PLUS OUR AGENCY
VISIT PLASTER AND A NUMBER OF
OTHER ENTITIES.
WE ARE COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH
THE STATE TO ADVANCE THE HOUSING
SUPPLY OBJECTIVES IN OUR REGION
IN THIS IS A VITAL PART TO BE
ABLE TO DELIVER AFFORDABLE
HOUSING.
IN PLASTER COUNTY -- WE ARE --
VERY CONCERNED OF HOW BAD THINGS
WITH A BE ABLE TO GET -- IN OUR
COUNTY IF WE WERE NOT ABLE TO
BECOME A SELF HELP COUNTY.
AND THAT'S WHY THIS BILL IS
BACKED BY SO MANY DIVERSE GROUPS
IT'S BACKED AS I MENTIONED BY
SAY COG THE SOLANO COUNTY
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION.
THE HUMBLE COUNTY TRANSPORTATION
DISTRICT.
THE CALIFORNIA CAL CALLED THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIAION OF LOCAL
COUNCILS OF GOVERNMENT
SACRAMENTO REGIONAL TRANSIT SELF
HELP COUNTIES WHICH IS THE
TWENTY SIX COUNTIES THAT WERE
MENTIONED BY MISTER AHRP.
RURAL COUNTIES TASK FORCE AND
MANY OTHER PARTNER AGENCIES
WE'RE HERE TO AT TODAY TO ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF AB.
FOURTEEN THIRTEEN PLEASE GIVE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITIES ANOTHER
TOOL TO HELP US HELP OURSELVES
THANK THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF THE
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
MR NAME IN YOUR TITLE AND
MANAGER MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE
AND HE FEELS FOR IN THAT
STRATEGIES ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA LINES FOR JOBS
AFOREMENTIONED GROUP I STRONGLY
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
AND CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE ANTHONY CAN SOLVE US
REPRESENTING THE CITY OF
ROSEVILLE WERE IN SUPPORT WHEN I
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR THE AN
INSTRUCTION.
KAREN L<c.cyan>G ON THE OTHER THE</c>
SOLANO TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY
IN THE PLAZA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS BOTH IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MATT CRIMMINS ONLY HALF THE
CALIFORNIA THAT A CONFERENCE OF
OPERATING ENGINEERS WE GOT A
LETTER IN LATE BUT WE'RE HAPPY
TO BE HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
HI MARC WATTS REPRESENTING --
CONTRA COSTA.
COUNTY TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR EDDIE BERNACCHI A
MAP THE NATIONAL ELECTRICAL
CONTRACTORS ASSOCIATION ALSO
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES
OPPOSITION
.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER WOLF.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS GOOD
AFTERNOON.
DAVID OFF BARRETT JARVIS
TAXPAYERS ASSOCIATION --
UNFORTUNATELY OPPOSED TO YOU AB
FOURTEEN THIRTEEN HERE TODAY --
MEMBERS WERE BROADLY SPEAKING
JEST -- CONCERNED WITH THE
AUTHORITY THAT'S BEEN PUT IN
PLACE HERE TO SET A SALES TAX ON
ONLY A PORTION OF IT
JURISDICTIONS TERRITORY -- THIS
IS PRECEDENT SETTING IN MANY
WAYS OTHER MUNICIPALITIES HAVE
DONE THIS BEFORE BUT YOU KNOW
IT'S IT'S ONLY BEEN DONE A
HANDFUL OF TIMES ACROSS THE
STATE.
OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS AND
WE'RE CONCERNED AND THE YOU KNOW
THE THE THERE BEEN OTHER GROUPS
OVER THE YEARS THAT HAVE
EXPRESSED THIS CONCERN Q. JUST
WITH REGARDS TO TAX COMPLIANCE.
YOU KNOW ANYTIME YOU'RE PICKING.
WINNERS AND LOSERS WITHIN
DIFFERENT JURISDICTIONS ARE IF
YOU'RE TARGETING AND
INCORPORATED AREA OF THE CITY OR
COUNTY OR MUNICIPALITY -- IT
DOES MAKE TAX COMPLIANCE MORE
DIFFICULT -- AND JUST AGAIN
PICKING AND CHOOSING WHAT YOUR
TAX BASE IS GOING TO BE -- AND
THEN OBVIOUSLY JUST MORE BROADLY
SPEAKING THE CONSUMER ARGUMENTS
CALIFORNIA ALREADY HAS THE
HIGHEST SALES TAX IN THE NATION
BY FAR.
AND WE SHOULDN'T BE MAKING IT
EASIER WITHIN THIS LEGISLATURE
AUTHORIZED ADDITIONAL VERY
REGRESSIVE SALES TAX EXACTIONS
SO FOR THOSE REASONS WOULD ASK
FOR NO VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF THE
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE.
LIKE TO ENTERTAIN SOMEONE
ENTERTAIN A MOTION.
HELLO MOVE THE BELL.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
HOW TO SAY VERY QUICKLY MAN
CHAIR I WAS PART OF AN EFFORT TO
TRY ENDING -- INCREASE
INFRASTRUCTURE SPENDING IN SAN
DIEGO COUNTY TWENTY SIXTEEN WITH
A PRESIDENT COALITION
REPUBLICANS DEMOCRATS BUSINESS
AND LABOR COME TOGETHER I
MEASURE PASSED WITH 58% OF THE
VOTE BUT AS YOU WELL KNOW THAT'S
NOT SUFFICIENT TO ACTUALLY MOVE
FOR THESE IMPROVEMENTS. 50% OF
THE PEOPLE WANTED SOMETHING
INCENDIO COUNTY WE COULDN'T GET
IT ONLY 46% OF PEOPLE VOTED FOR
THE PRESENT I STATES AND HE'S
THERE SO I THINK WHEN YOU TALK
ABOUT DOING THINGS A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENTLY -- THIS TOOL IS
MEANT TO ADDRESS THAT I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
FOR INFRASTRUCTURE FOR JOBS FOR
IMPROVING MOVING CALIFORNIA.
FOR THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER --
GLORIA ALSO BE SUPPORTING YOUR
BILL TODAY I ALWAYS APPRECIATE
THE WORK YOU'RE DOING TO LOOK
OUTSIDE THE BOX AND LOOK FOR A
DIFFERENT FUNDING SOLUTIONS SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- SECRETARY
TAKE GROWTH.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY I A
LACKEY BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE BURNER **** BATH.
BOERNER HORVATH I RAMOS THREE OF
US.
THREE OF US SIDE ROBERT RIVAS
ROBERT RIVAS I VOEPEL
[inaudible]
VOEPEL NO.
BILLS OUT FIVE TO ONE YOU CAN
CHECK THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- I
THINK SINCE WE DON'T HAVE.
DO WE HAVE SOMEONE HERE.
THE CONSENT CALENDAR YES GIVEN
UP MISS CONSULTS FLETCHER ASKED
ME TO PRESENT HER BILL AND SHE
IS ABLE TO PRESENT HERSELF --
WELL HELLO.
BUT PLEASE DO THE CONSENT AGENDA.
YEAH.
DO WE WANT.
TO WE'RE GONNA DO OUR CONSENT
COUNCIL REAL QUICK WHILE WE HAVE
EVERYBODY HERE -- FOR MOST HERE --
SECRETARY.
WE NEED A MOTION THE SECOND
CONSECUTIVE UNDER [inaudible]
HELLO.
AGUIAR-CURRY I AGUIAR-CURRY I
LACKEY BLOOM.
ROOM I'VE BURNER FOR VAST.
BOERNER HORVATH I RAMOS THREE OF
US.
THREE OF US I ROBERT RIVAS.
ROBERT RIVAS I VOEPEL.
HOW HIGH?
A CONSENSUS SIX ZERO WILL NOT
MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER NINE AB
SEVENTEEN THIRTY ASSEMBLY MERRY
MEMBER GOOD GONZALEZ FOR ME
EVERY PRESENTED BY OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GLORIA THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR STEPPING IN TODAY.
MY ABSOLUTE PLEASURE TO BE HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE CHAIR THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
AB THIRD JUST.
AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY WOULD EXTEND
THE DEADLINE FOR STANDING
ASSOCIATION OF GOVERNMENTS TO
FINALIZE A NEW REGIONAL
TRANSPORTATION PLAN.
BY TWO YEARS -- I HAVE TWO
WITNESSES WHO ARE HERE -- MORE
TOP WITH THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO.
AND ROBIN.
WATER SORRY TO ME AS I ROBIN AND
AND THIS IS THEIR PLACE IN THE
CITY -- CESSATION GOVERNMENTS.
GREAT WELCOME THANK YOU YES
ROBIN WALKER WITH THE SAN DIEGO
ASSOCIATION OF GOVERNMENTS WE
ARE HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF IN
A PROUD SPONSOR OF AB SEVENTEEN
THIRTY WERE VERY THANKFUL. FOR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GONZALEZ THE
SUPPORT OF THE BILL I'M IT'S
PRETTY STRAIGHTFORWARD A COUPLE
MONTHS AGO OUR BOARD OF
DIRECTORS UNANIMOUSLY APPROVED
TAKING A TWO YEAR EXTENSION TO
DEVELOP OUR NEXT REGIONAL
TRANSPORTATION PLAN AND
SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITY STRATEGY.
AND SO THIS BILL GIVES US THE
AUTHORITY TO DO THAT TO TAKE THE
TIME GO BACK TO THE DRAWING
BOARD AND REALLY DO THIS RIGHT
CREATE A VISIONARY
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM. FOR OUR
REGION THAT -- NOT NOT ONLY
MEETS BUT EXCEEDS THE STATE WIDE
CLIMATE TARGETS THAT WE ARE
COMMITTED TO ACHIEVING I'M AT
THE SAME TIME WE RECOGNIZE HOW
IMPORTANT HOUSING IS SO THIS
BILL ALSO MAKE SURE THAT WE STAY
ON TRACK FOR SIX CYCLE OF RINA.
A SO WE CAN CONTINUE TO BUILD
THAT THE HOUSES THAT WE SO
SORELY NEED SO WITH THAT WE'VE
ENJOYED A UNANIMOUS APPROVAL AS
I SAID FROM OUR BOARD OF
DIRECTORS ALL THE LOCAL CITIES
AND THE COUNTY OF SAN DIEGO.
AS WELL AS A BROAD RANGE OF
STAKEHOLDERS THROUGHOUT THE
REGION AND WE WOULD APPRECIATE
YOUR SUPPORT TODAY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS MORE TOP ON BEHALF
OF THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO WE TOO
ARE PROUD CO SPONSORS.
OF THE MEASURE ON THE CITY
ADOPTED A ROBUST AGGRESSIVE COME
ON CLIMATE ACTION PLAN RECENTLY.
AND WE ARE CERTAINLY SEE SANDBAG
US PARTNERS WITH US IN ORDER FOR
US TO TO MEET OUR GOALS --
HOPEFULLY EXCEED SOME OF THE
STATE GOALS SO WE'RE VERY PROUD
OF WHAT WE'RE DOING THERE BUT WE
DO NEED THIS BILL IN ORDER -- TO
AS A STANDARD REPRESENTATIVE
INDICATED TO GET IT RIGHT I
WOULD THINK THIS BILL IS
INTEGRAL IN ORDER FOR US TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH OUR PLAN WE ASK FOR
YOUR ABOUT.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT -- YES MAN AND
CHAIR RICHARD HARRIS SOME HAVE
THE SAN DIEGO COUNTY REGIONAL
AIRPORT AUTHORITY IN SUPPORT.
JOHN SINCLAIR BACK TO THE CITY
EVENTS IN IN THIS IN THE PORT OF
SAN DIEGO ALSO IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
CATHERINE AGREED ON ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY OF CARLSBAD IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT SEEING NONE
ANY WOULDN'T WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SAYING THAT ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE.
YES AND SOME REMEMBER BURNER HER
RIGHT.
OR BACK I KNOW RUN OVER.
THERE -- I JUST WANNA ACTUALLY
THINK EVERYBODY FOR REALLY
WORKING ON THIS -- THE NEW
VISION THAT'S BEING PROPOSED IS
SO MUCH BETTER FOR CLIMATE
ACTION GOES SO MUCH BETTER FOR
NORTH COUNTY THE AREA I
REPRESENT.
I AM SO THANKFUL THAT YOU'RE
DOING THE RIGHT THING AND TAKING
THIS FOR IT SO I'LL BE ABSOLUTE
SUPPORTING THIS AND I COMMEND
YOU GUYS FOR FOR REALLY.
MAKING A DIFFERENCE IN OUR
COUNTY THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
I NEED A MOTION AND SECOND.
MOVE THE BILL.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE ON
BEHALF OF MS GONZALEZ I JUST
APPRECIATE YOUR CONSIDERATION OF
THIS BILL GIVE SAN DIEGO THE
OPPORTUNITY TO GET IT RIGHT --
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
WHAT I LIKE ABOUT THIS IS THAT
WATCHING LOCALS IN REGIONAL
PEOPLE WORK TOGETHER TO COME UP
WITH SOLUTIONS?
AND THEN YOU GUYS OF I KNOW WORK
VERY HARD FOR A FIGHT SOME TIME
TO DO THIS AND WHY STOP
SOMETHING THAT'S WORKING REALLY
WELL SO -- CONGRATULATIONS AND I
WILL BE SUPPORTING YOUR BILL
TODAY.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AGUIAR-CURRY AGUIAR-CURRY I A
LACKEY BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE BOERNER HORVATH.
BOERNER HORVATH I RAMOS.
RAMOS SIDE THREE OF US THREE OF
US CYBER ROBERT RIVAS.
ROBERT RIVERSIDE VOEPEL REGIONAL --
VOEPEL I BILLS AT SEVEN ZERO
THEY CAN CHECK.
YOU'RE VERY WELCOME -- NEXT IT
IS WALDRON.
I'M BEFORE YOU MOVE ON I'M GOING
TO GO AHEAD AND WE'RE GOING TO
LEARN.
JUST GET THE VOTE WE NEED A
MOTION.
AND A SECOND FOR ITEM NUMBER
FOUR AB TEN FIFTY THREE DOLLY.
YOUR MOTION AND A SECOND -- AS A
SECRETARY.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I LACKEY.
BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE BURNER HER BACK.
BOERNER HORVATH I RAMOS.
RAMOS I THREE OF US THREE OF US
I ROBERT RIVAS.
ROBERT RIVAS I VOEPEL
[inaudible]
ITEM[inaudible]
FOR RIGHT [inaudible]
VOEPEL I BILLS AT SEVEN ZERO
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN A. B. THIRTEEN NO
FAR.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WALDRON WELCOME
.
THANK YOU SO MUCH GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIRWOMAN AND MEMBERS I
MISS THIS COMMITTEE SO I'M HAPPY
TO BE BACK TO VISIT MY BILL --
FIRST I'D LIKE TO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS.
AND I THINK THE COMMITTEE STAFF
FOR THEIR HARD WORK ON THIS
ISSUE WITH ME -- THIS IS
BASICALLY A SIMPLE BILL IT WOULD
ENABLE A WATER DISTRICT CONTRACT
WITH THE NATIVE AMERICAN TRIBE
TO RECEIVE WATER DELIVERIES FROM
AN INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS ON
TRIBAL LANDS.
IN TWO YEARS AGO WE FACILITATED
THE PROVISION OF DRINKING WATER
TO TRIBAL LANDS THROUGH AB
THIRTEEN SIXTY ONE WHICH WAS
EDUARDO GARCIA AND I THAT
BASICALLY ALLOWED WATER
DISTRICTS TO SERVICE TRIBAL
LANDS SO THIS IS KIND OF JUST
THE OPPOSITE EXCHANGE -- TO
FACILITATE THE FLOW THE OTHER
WAY.
SO -- PAM LOPEZ REPRESENTING THE
RING CONN BAND OF INDIANS IS
WITH US TODAY. TO PROVIDE ANY
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION ON THE
ISSUE.
GOOD AFTERNOON WELCOME GOOD
AFTERNOON PAN LOPEZ ON BEHALF OF
THE RING CONN BAND OF LEWIS AND
YOU INDIANS.
THE SIMPLE BILL WE UNDERSTAND
IT'S STILL A BIT OF A WORK IN
PROGRESS -- BUT THE TRIBE LOOKS
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR I. AS WE MOVE FORWARD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHER OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE -- IS THERE ANY
QUESTION -- YES I AM SO SORRY.
AND UP TO WHERE.
I WAS MAYBE YOU WERE IN BETWEEN --
THE BILL -- THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS I'M BOB READ WITH
READ GOVERNMENT RELATIONS TODAY
ON BEHALF OF DESERT WATER AGENCY.
IT'S LIKELY COUNTERINTUITIVE
THAT A ONE SENTENCE BILL COULD
HAVE SO MUCH PACKED INTO IN
TERMS OF CONTROVERSY BUT ALLOW
ME TO EXPLAIN WHAT THE ISSUES
ARE -- WITH THIS BILL.
FIRST AND FOREMOST IS IT
CONTRAVENES FEDERAL LAW.
WHEN THE CONGRESS OR THE
PRESIDENT ESTABLISHES A
RESERVATION -- FOR INDIANS
INDIAN TRIBE.
IT -- CREATES THAT WITH THE
INTENTION OF ALLOWING THE
SETTLEMENTS TO BECOME SELF
RELIANT SELF SUFFICIENT.
UNDER THE WINTERS DOCTRINE WHICH
I COMMUNICATED WITH THE
COMMITTEE ABOUT WHEN THE
CONGRESS RESERVES LANDS THAT
ALSO RESERVES WATER SUFFICIENT
TO FULFILL THE PURPOSES OF THE
RESERVATION.
AS A MATTER OF FEDERAL LAW.
AN INDIAN TRIBE DOES NOT HAVE
THE RIGHT TO MARKET ITS
FACTORIES ARE OF WATER RIGHT.
FOR OFF RESERVATION USE.
IF AN INDIAN TRIBE INTENDS TO
SELL ITS RESERVE WATER TO A
THIRD PARTY FOR USE OFF THE
RESERVATION.
THEN THE WATER BY DEFINITION IS
BEYOND THAT WHICH IS NECESSARY.
FOR USE ON THE RESERVATION TO
FILL FULFILL THE RESERVATION
PURPOSES AND THE TRIBE DOES NOT
HAVE A RESERVE RIGHT FOR THAT
WATER.
SECOND THERE'S THIS -- SUPPOSE
THAT NEED FOR MORE WATER STORES
IN CALIFORNIA I WOULD REMIND THE
COMMITTEE RESPECTFULLY THAT
PROPOSITION ONE OF TWENTY
FOURTEEN SOME OF YOU WERE STILL --
WE'RE HERE -- SET SET ASIDE TWO
POINT SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS FOR
INVESTMENTS IN NEW WATER STORAGE
PROJECTS IN CALIFORNIA.
THE WATER COMMISSION AND IS
ADMINISTERING THE WATER STORES
INVESTMENT PROGRAM.
THEY CALLED FOR PROJECTS TO BE
BROUGHT FORWARD AND APPROVED
FUNDING FOR EIGHT PROJECTS --
WITH A MAXIMUM WATER STORAGE
CAPACITY FOUR POINT THREE
MILLION ACRE FEET.
NONE OF THOSE PROJECTS RUN
RESERVATION LANDS -- AND FINALLY --
WHAT WE'RE LOOKING AT HERE IS
SINCE THIS IS THE AUTHOR REMOVED
GROUNDWATER IS ONE OF THE WATER
SOURCES THAT MAY BE USED UNDER
THE BILL WE'RE DEALING WITH TWO
OTHER SOURCES SPRING?
WHICH IS NOT SUFFICIENT TO BE
DIVERTED TO SUPPORT A MUNICIPAL
PURPOSE OR DAM MEAN A RIVER OR
STREAM.
THERE'S NO OTHER WAY TO DEVELOP
WATER ON A RESERVATION SITE
OTHER THAN THOSE.
TWO AND I CAN JUST SAY THAT --
BASED ON EXPERIENCE THAT THERE
ARE SUCH STREAMS AND RIVERS --
IT'S QUESTIONABLE WHETHER TRY
WOULD SUPPORT CONSTRUCTION OF A
DAM AND RESERVOIR ON TRIBAL
LANDS.
A NATIVE AMERICAN PEOPLE'S HAVE
HAD CONTINUAL INTERACTS WITH
RIVERS AND STREAMS OVER SEVERAL
MILLENNIA AND THEIR SOCIAL
ADDITIONAL AND SPIRITUAL
ACTIVITIES HAVE BECOME
INSEPARABLE FROM THE RIVERS
THEMSELVES -- YOU DON'T ONE CAN
ONLY LOOK TO THE HOOP BUT KERIK
IN EUROPE TRIBES IN THE NORTH
COAST.
AND THE WOMEN WENT TO TRIBE
WHO'S FIGHTING THE SHASTA DAM
REYES.
NOW THE SHASTA DAM REYES WAS NOT
ONE OF THE EIGHT PROJECTS ON THE
WATER COMMISSION LIST.
BUT THE WOMEN WENT TO TRIBE
ARGUES THAT WITHOUT THEIR SACRED
SITES ALONG THE CLOUD RIVER.
WHICH WE WOULD BE LOST
INUNDATION WOMEN CULTURE COULD
NO LONGER EXIST SO THERE THERE'S
ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES WITH THIS
BILL.
THERE'S CONFLICT WITH FEDERAL
RESERVE RIGHTS AND ESTABLISHED
FEDERAL LAW.
THERE'S ALSO POTENTIAL DAMAGE TO
WRITE TYRIAN SYSTEMS.
NATIVE AMERICAN FISHERIES
SUBSTANCE FISHERIES AND WHAT
HAVE YOU AND I REALIZE THIS IS
LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE AND
TO BRING THESE ISSUES BEFORE
THIS COMMITTEE IS A BIT OF A
CHALLENGE.
BUT THIS WAS SINGLE REFERRED TO
THIS COMMITTEE IT REALLY SHOULD
HAVE BEEN IN THE WATER COMMITTEE
BUT AGAIN A ONE SENTENCE BILL.
BUT IT IT BRINGS A LOT OF
CONTROVERSIAL ISSUES TO THE
TABLE AND I FELT COMPELLED ON
BEHALF OF THE WATER AGENCY TO
BRING THESE BEFORE YOU TODAY.
AND BE PLEASED TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE THERE
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION OF THIS
BILL.
SAYING THAT ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS OF THE COMMITTEE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM.
I JUST WANNA SAY I'M CONCERNED
THAT -- BY THE COMMENTS THAT
I'VE HEARD FROM -- THE
OPPOSITION -- I'D APPRECIATE IT
IF THE PROPONENT COULD ADDRESS
THEM AND I'M INCLINED TO MOVE
THE BILL FORWARD TODAY -- BUT
WOULD.
ARE.
PENDING RECEIPT OF ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION -- RESERVE MY VOTE
ON THE FLOOR.
WELL -- THANK YOU MISTER BLOOM
AND AS WE KNOW NATIVE AMERICAN
TRIBES ARE SOVEREIGN NATIONS.
THEY HAVE THEIR OWN -- TREATIES
AND AGREEMENTS WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT THIS BILL AS A STATE
BILL DOES NOT SUPERSEDE ANY OF
THAT -- IN FACT THE BILL
LANGUAGE INCLUDES THAT NOTHING
WILL.
DETER -- NOTHING IN THIS SECTION
DETERMINES OUR ALTERS EXISTING
WATER RIGHTS -- THE BILL WOULD
NOT INFRINGE ON THEIR
SOVEREIGNTY AND IT IN IN THE
FACT THE BILL AFFECTS THE
AUTHORITY OF WATER DISTRICTS TO
ACT.
IT DOES NOT IN ANY WAY AFFECT
TRIBES TO ACT OR TO DO ANYTHING
[inaudible]
SOME [inaudible]
ASSEMBLYMEMBER -- LOUIS RIGHT
FROM THIS.
THANK YOU MANAGER AND THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONCERN FOR AND THE
WATER DISTRICT AS FAR AS
PROTECTING NATIVE AMERICAN
RESOURCES THAT ARE THERE.
HOPEFULLY WE'LL HEAR THAT.
LATER ON IN DIFFERENT DIALOG IN
DIFFERENT ENGAGEMENTS WITH THE
TRIBES AND DOWN THE ROAD.
BUT GETTING BACK -- TO THOUGH
THE WATER RESOURCES ON THE
RESERVATION BEING ABLE TO SELL
THOSE -- AREAS I KNOW OF THE
FUTURE LIVES THAT ARE CURRENTLY
DOING THAT -- SELLING THE WATERS
TO DIFFERENT AREAS DIFFERENT --
<c.magenta>ANUFACTURES THAT ARE OUT THERE</c>
AS A MATTER OF FACT THERE'S ONE
OUT IN -- IN IN NEEDLES IN THE
AREA OUT THERE THERE'S PROVIDING
WATER TO THE CITY -- SO THAT IS
ON GOING AND I THINK BEING ABLE --
TO SUPPORT THE THIS BILL MOVIE
FOR SOMETHING THAT THAT I WILL
DO AND COURAGE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE TO ALSO DOING WITH
THAT AMOUNT OF CHARM OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER COMMITMENTS
ANY OTHER COMMENTS.
OKAY WE HAVE A MOTION.
AND WE HAVE A SECOND.
OF SOME ROOM -- THIS RIVER SAYS
THE SECOND OKAY.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AS WE KNOW
WATER IS ONE OF MY OUR MOST
PRECIOUS RESOURCES.
AND WE IT'S STILL ESTIMATED THAT
MORE THAN A MILLION CALIFORNIANS
DID NOT HAVE ACCESS TO CLEAN
WATER -- BY ALLOWING WATER
DISTRICTS TO RECEIVE WATER
DELIVERIES FROM INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECTS ON TOP TRIBAL LANDS
IT'S A POTENTIAL SUPPLY SIDE
SOLUTION AS WELL. FOR ADDITIONAL
WATER AND I ASK FOR YOUR IPHONE --
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER -- FOR ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO ADD AFIVE
YEAR SUNSET DATE.
THIS WILL HELP THE LEGISLATURE
RETAIN OVERSIGHT OF THIS NEW
AUTHORITY SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND WITH THAT THE SECRETARY.
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I A LACKEY BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE BOERNER HORVATH.
BOERNER HORVATH I RAMOS.
FROM ASIDE THREE OF US.
THREE OF US I ROBERT RIVAS.
ROBERT RIVAS FIVE VOEPEL.
VOEPEL HI.
MEASURES OF SEVEN ZERO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH IN A TWO ONE COME BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE YOU'RE MORE
THAN WELCOME TO COME THANK YOU
SO MUCH.
OKAY -- NEXT WE HAVE US SIMPLY
ITEM NUMBER SIX AB TWELVE ZERO
EIGHT ASSEMBLYMEMBER TING
WELCOME.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR FIRST --
TO LET ME TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
HELP AND YOUR COMMITTEE STAFF
HELP WITH.
AB TWELVE AWAIT THIS BILL ACT
ACTUALLY EXTENSION.
OF A BILL THAT OUR COLLEAGUE
MISTER NOLAN DID IN TWENTY
THIRTEEN WHICH IS -- TO CONTINUE
THE PROHIBITION ON UTILITY USERS
TAX ON CLEAN ENERGY.
AS YOU KNOW -- UTILITY USERS TAX
COULD BE IMPOSED BY LOCAL
JURISDICTION ON THE CONSUMPTION
OF UTILITY SERVICES.
INCLUDING AMONG OTHER THINGS
ELECTRICITY GAS WATER SEWER AND
TELEPHONE.
AGAIN -- THERE WAS A SUNSET DATE
PLACED ON THIS IN TWENTY
THIRTEEN TO SUNSET IS COMING UP
AND WE ARE AXING FOR EXTENSION.
THANK YOUR THOSE OTHERS IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MY NAME IS BEN DAVIS I
AM A POLICY ASSOCIATE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SOLAR AND STORAGE
ASSOCIATION.
WE ARE SPONSORS OF THE BILL
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
COME AND TESTIFY BRIEFLY.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE OH EIGHT IS
A BENEFICIAL AND RELATIVELY
SIMPLE PIECE OF LEGISLATION.
THE UTILITY USER TAX EXEMPTION
ON THE ENERGY THAT GOES FROM THE
SOLAR PANELS ON A ROOF DIRECTLY
TO THAT HOME WHERE THAT
CUSTOMERS LIGHTS AND OUTLETS AND
OTHER LOADS.
THAT -- EXIT EXEMPTION IS
EXPIRING IN JANUARY.
TWENTY TWENTY A. B. TWELVE AWAY
BUT SIMPLY EXTEND THAT EXEMPTION
TO JANUARY [inaudible]
TWENTY TWENTY SEVEN WHEN
CALIFORNIANS GENERATE CLEAN
ENERGY SAFELY ON THEIR OWN ROOF
OR THEIR ON PREMISES.
THEY SHOULD BE ABLE TO USE THAT
CLEAN ENERGY WITHOUT OBSTRUCTION
INTERFERENCE OR TAX FROM THE
GOVERNMENT.
AND AS THE COMMITTEE KNOWS THE
STATE HAS AMBITIOUS GOALS TO
TACKLE CLIMATE CHANGE AND WE
SHOULD BE INCENTIVIZING ALL
CALIFORNIANS TO USE RENEWABLE
ENERGY WE SHOULDN'T BE PUTTING
UP BARRIERS BY TAXING THEM.
AND AB TWELVE OH EIGHT
ACCOMPLISHES THAT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE
[inaudible]
THANK.
THANK YOU WE HAVE A MOTION --
ARE THERE ANY OTHER -- MEMBERS
IN SUPPORT [inaudible]
OR HE WENT OUT TO THE ONE
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON THAT CLUB AND SEE
NO BEHALF THE SOLAR ENERGY
INDUSTRIES ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NICK BROKE OUT HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY STORAGE
ALLIANCE HERE IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
UP TO MANAGER MEMBERS ABOUT A
TRICKLE MAP OF SOMEONE IN THE
LAND FOR SOLAR CHOICE.
ALSO APPEARING ON BEHALF OF
BORREGO SOLAR MY COLLEAGUES WERE
UNABLE TO ATTEND ALL IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON WE APPARENTLY ON
BEHALF OF TEST LE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION [inaudible]
WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS CARE AWESOME BEHALF OF
THE CITY OF PASADENA AND
UNFORTUNATELY WE MUST
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THE BILL.
THE CITY VOTERS APPROVED THERE
YOU YOU T. IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT
LOCAL VOTERS TO LET THEIR CITY
COUNCIL MEMBERS TO MAKE PUBLIC
POLICY IN RESPONSE TO LOCAL
NEEDS.
DECIDING HOW TO APPLY LOCAL
TAXES TO GENERATE LOCAL REVENUES
IS PRECISELY WHAT COUNCIL
MEMBERS ARE ELECTED TO DO.
EXEMPTING CLEAN ENERGY RESOURCES
FROM YOU YOU TEASE ROADS LOCAL
OFFICIALS ABILITY TO MANAGE
LOCAL AFFAIRS BY MAKING IT MORE
DIFFICULT FOR THEM TO RAISE
GENERAL FUND REVENUES.
LOCAL ELECTED OFFICIALS AND THE
VOTERS TO HIM THERE ACCOUNTABLE
ARE THE BEST PERSON TO JUDGE THE
MERITS OF IMPOSING A YOU UT.
THERE ARE THESE ARE PLANS ARE
VERY CRITICAL AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
THEY GO TO FUND PUBLIC SAFETY
SERVICES POLICE FIRE PARKS --
AND LIBRARIES THEIR FUNDAMENTAL
TO OUR COMMUNITY EXTENDING A
STATE MANDATED EXEMPTION OF A
LOCALLY APPROVED LOCALLY
COLLECTED REVENUE SOURCE IS WE
BELIEVE THE SIMPLY BAD POLICY.
WELL THE BILL HAS NOBLE GOALS TO
HELP RENEWABLE ENERGY IN THE
FUTURE AND WE LIKE THE STATE ARE
HEADED TOWARDS A 100% CLEAN
ENERGY.
WE BELIEVE THAT'S THE THE
EXTENSION OF THIS MEASURE HAS
FAR REACHING REVENUE
IMPLICATIONS.
THAT HAVE THE POTENTIAL TO HAVE
SEVERE CONSEQUENCES FOR CITIES
AND COUNTIES IN THE FUTURE AND
WITHOUT RESPECTFULLY ASPIRIN
ABOUT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHER OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SINGER ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS
OF THE COMMITTEE.
I HAVE I HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I
JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE
VOTE IN IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN AS WE
REMEMBER WE PASSED SB ONE
HUNDRED TO GET US TO A 1100%
RENEWABLE.
I THINK IT MAKES SENSE TO EXTEND
THIS -- EXEMPTION IN THE IN
AROUND TWO TO HELP US GET THERE
WITHOUT RESPECT FAST RIGHT UP.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR BECAUSE
SOMEONE MEMBER TEAM FOR
ACCEPTING A COMEDIAN MMS REMOVE
THE LANGUAGE PERTAINING TO
STORAGE FACILITIES AND TODAY
I'LL BE SUPPORTING YOUR BILL.
THANK YOU.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
AGUIAR-CURRY I AGUIAR-CURRY I
LACKEY BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE BOERNER HORVATH.
BOERNER HORVATH I RAMOS.
FROM ASIDE THREE OF US.
THREE OF US I ROBERT RIVAS.
ROBERT RIVAS FIVE VOEPEL.
VOEPEL HI.
CLOSE AT SEVEN ZERO THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT WE WILL
HAVE IT LOOKS LIKE -- GOOD
AFTERNOON MR MULLIN HIS ITEM
NUMBER THREE AB NINE NINE TO
WELCOME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
PRESENTING AB.
ADDING AB.
NINE NINE TWO AB NINE AND TWO
SIMPLY CLARIFIES THAT MEMBERS OF
A LOCAL ELECTED BODY MAY ENGAGE
IN SOCIAL MEDIA.
PROVIDED THEY DO NOT INTERACT IN
ANY WAY THAT VIOLATES THE RALPH
M. BROWN ACT.
SPECIFICALLY AB NINE NINE TWO
ALLOWS MEMBERS TO USE SOCIAL
MEDIA.
PROVIDED THAT A MAJORITY OF
MEMBERS DO NOT DISCUSS AMONG
THEMSELVES BUSINESS OF A
SPECIFIC NATURE.
THAT IS WITHIN THE SUBJECT
MATTER JURISDICTION OF THE
LEGISLATIVE BODY.
OR OR LOCAL AGENCY LET ME BE
CLEAR.
AB NINE NINE TWO DOES NOT
UNDERMINE EXISTING BROWN ACT
PROHIBITIONS.
BUT CLARIFIES THE GRAY AREA THAT
MANY LOCAL GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS
AND THEIR LEGAL TEAMS ARE
STRUGGLING WITH.
WHEN CONNECTING WITH THEIR
CONSTITUENTS?
WITH EVOLVING FORMS OF
COMMUNICATION AND PARTICIPATION
IN SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS LOCAL
OFFICIALS ARE INDICATING TO ME.
THAT IT IS UNCLEAR WHAT IS
ALLOWED WHEN INTERACTING WITH
THE PUBLIC ON SOCIAL MEDIA.
SOMETHING NOT CONSIDERED WHEN
THE BROWN ACT WAS FIRST ENACTED
IN.
NINETEEN FIFTY THREE THE
DEMOCRATIZING ASPECT OF SOCIAL
MEDIAS THAT A GIVE CITIZENS
NEARLY FULL ACCESS TO THEIR
ELECTED OFFICIALS.
PRIOR TO THE ADVENT OF SOCIAL
MEDIA CONSTITUENTS ONLY ACCESS
WAS TO MAKE AN APPOINTMENT TO
SEE THEIR ELECTED OFFICIAL.
HAPPEN TO RUN INTO THEM WHEN
THEY'RE OUT ABOUT FOUR TEN
COUNCIL MEETINGS TODAY THE
PUBLIC HAS TWENTY FOUR HOUR
ACCESS AND CAN VOICE THEIR
OPINIONS.
I UNDERSTAND THERE ARE CONCERNS
REGARDING HOW NARROW SOME OF THE
DEFINITIONS MIGHT BE.
THE INTENTION IS TO PROVIDE
ENOUGH GUIDANCE FOR THE COURTS
TO DECIDE WHAT CONSTITUTES A
VIOLATION WHEN ISSUES DO OCCUR.
THIS BILL DOES NOT ENCOURAGE OR
ALLOW LOCAL OFFICIALS TO
DELIBERATE.
WITHOUT NOTICE ON SOCIAL MEDIA
BUT INSTEAD PROVIDE STRUCTURE
AND CLARITY TO INTERACTIONS THAT
ARE MOST LIKELY ALREADY
HAPPENING ONLINE.
I ALSO UNDERSTAND THAT ACCESS TO
SOCIAL MEDIA IS NOT 1100% BUT
THAT IS A SEPARATE ISSUE THE
DIGITAL DIVIDE ISSUE WHICH A
CONCERN THAT I SHARE.
WITH MADAM CHAIR.
BUT THE FACT IS MOST CITIZENS
TODAY ARE CONNECTED ONLINE AND
MANY TO SOCIAL MEDIA AS A WAY TO
INTERACT WITH THEIR ELECTED.
AND I'M SURE WE ALL EXPERIENCE
FROM OUR OWN SOCIAL MEDIA
INTERACTIONS MANY OF THOSE
CITIZENS ARE VERY COMFORTABLE
EXPRESSING THEIR OPINIONS.
ON ISSUES THAT MATTER TO THEM.
TO TO PUT IT LIGHTLY OUGHT TO
EXCLUDE A SOCIAL MEDIA
PARTICIPATION HARM CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT AND DOES A DISSERVICE
TO THE PUBLIC WHILE UNDERMINING
TRANSPARENCY.
I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO NOTE THAT
AS WE WERE WORKING ON A DRAFT OF
A AB NINE NINE TWO WE
SPECIFICALLY ASKED LEGISLATIVE
COUNSEL WHETHER IN THEIR OPINION
WE WERE DOING ANYTHING TO
UNDERMINE THE BROWN ACT BECAUSE
THAT'S NOT SOMETHING I WANT TO
BE ASSOCIATED WITH.
THEIR ANSWER WAS DEFINITIVELY NO.
AS I CONVEYED TO THEM AND THEY
UNDERSTOOD WHAT WE ARE TRYING TO
DO IS TO SIMPLY CLARIFY WHAT'S
APPROPRIATE AND WHAT'S NOT IN
THE DIGITAL AGE.
WE ARE OPEN TO CONTINUE WORKING
ON LANGUAGE TO REFINE THE BILL
IN THE LAST TWENTY FOUR HOURS WE
WE RECEIVE SEVERAL COMMENTS ON
HOW.
TO A BETTER APPROACH THIS ISSUE
AND AND TWEAK THE LANGUAGE I AM
HAPPY TO ENGAGE WITH MEMBERSOF
THIS COMMITTEE.
AND TO THAT END OF ANY MEMBERS
WOULD LIKE TO SIGN ON AS CO
AUTHORS WE ALWAYS WELCOME THAT
OF COURSE WITH ME TODAY IS DANE
HUTCHINGS FROM THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES AS WELL AS
DEALING GIVEN FROM THE SPECIAL
DISTRICTS.
ASSOCIATION TO PRESENT THEIR
PERSPECTIVE.
THANK YOU ARE CHAIR MEMBERS TING
HUTCHINGS WITH THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES I DON'T KNOW
IF I COULD HAVE DONE QUITE AS
GOOD A JOB AS THE AS THE MEMBER
ARTICULATING THE IMPORTANCE OF
THE MEASURE -- BUT WE CERTAINLY
DO -- ARE TRUMP SUPPORT THE BILL --
AS AS THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER SAID
THAT WE WE ARE SIMPLY SEEKING
GUIDANCE I CAN TELL YOU
FIRSTHAND TALKING -- TO CITY
ATTORNEYS ACROSS THE STATE --
THEY HAVE CONFLICTING COUNSEL
SOME MEMBERS BELIEVE THEY CAN
ENGAGE A LITTLE BIT MORE SOME
FOLKS I ARE ARE ARE TAKING ALL
DO CAUTION NOT ENGAGING.
THE LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA CITIES
WAS THAT WITH THE CHIEF SPONSOR
THE BROWN ACT AS THE IT WE
ABSOLUTELY -- BELIEVE IN IN
TRANSPARENCY -- BELIEVE IN CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT WE BELIEVE AT THIS
BILL ENHANCES THAT -- YOU KNOW
WHEN AS THE MEMBER SAID -- THIS
MODERNIZE THE BROWN ACT TO
REFLECT THE USE OF SOCIAL MEDIA
AS REALLY THE NEW COMMUNITY
MEETING WE WHEN WHEN WORKING
WITH THE AUTHORS OFFICE ON
CRAFTING THIS MEASURE WE
SPECIFICALLY -- PUT IT INTO THE
COMMUNITY MEETINGS EXCEPTIONS IN
THE BROWN ACT THIS IS NOT --
TAKE AWAY OPTIONS FOR FOLKS WHO
DO NOT HAVE ACCESS TO THE
INTERNET I MEAN THIS IS SIMPLY
SAYING THAT YOU KNOW WHEN WE
HAVING IT PERHAPS A NEIGHBORHOOD
ASSOCIATION MEETING OR YOU NEED
THESE COMMITTEE MEETINGS WERE
ACCOUNT NUMBERS PERMITTED TO GO
AND AND AND EXPRESS THEIR VIEWS
AND OPINIONS.
WE'RE WE'RE PUTTING THIS IS IN
THE SAME AYE BECAUSE SOCIAL
MEDIA REALLY HAS BECOME THE NEW
PLACE WHERE PEOPLE CAN ACT AND
DISCUSS IMPORTANT ISSUES
PERTAINING TO THEIR TO THEIR
LOCAL GOVERNMENT -- YOU KNOW I I
KNOW THAT THERE IS SOME THERE IS
SOME OPPOSITION TO THE MEASURE I
HAVE SPOKEN -- TO THE THOSE
FOLKS WILL UNDOUBTEDLY BE COMING
UP IN UP AND AND SHARING THEIR
VIEWS THAT WE ARE VERY MUCH
WILLING TO WORK WITH THEM -- IT
SHOULD THE COMMITTEE -- MOVE
THIS MEASURE -- THE LAST THING
WE WANT TO DO -- IS IS UNDERMINE
THE INTENT OF THE BROWN ACT THIS
IS A STARTING POINT -- HOPING
THAT WE CAN CONTINUE TO WORK
TOGETHER TO CRAFT A SOLUTION
THAT WILL PROVIDE GUIDANCE TO
LOCAL OFFICIALS BY ENHANCING
TRANSPARENCY ENHANCING SEVEN
GAUGE ME.
THANK YOU -- CHAIR MEMBERS
COMMITTEES DON'T GIVENS WITH
CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION -- DON'T HAVE MUCH
MORE TO TO ADD TO THE ROBUST --
TESTIMONY THIS ALREADY BEEN
PROVIDED -- JUST. FOR PROPUBLICA
AGENCIES WE WE ARE CONTINUING TO
ENCOURAGE THEM -- TO ENGAGE IN
OUTREACH TO THE PUBLIC.
THIS BILL PROVIDES THAT CLEARLY
TO ALLOW THEM TO DO SO.
I THINK MANY OF YOU HAVE SERVED
IN A LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND AND
PREVIOUS CAPACITY YOU KNOW THE
FEAR THAT IS ASSOCIATED WITH THE
BROWN ACT IN THE SERIAL MEETINGS
AND THAT SOMETIMES IT THAT THAT
THAT CAUSES YOU TO DO.
NOTHING TO TO FREEZE UP TO TO
THEIR TO FEAR TO NOT -- GO OUT
AND AND COMMENTS AND SO THIS
BILL JUST PROVIDE THAT CLEARLY
IT ALLOWS.
PUBLIC OFFICIALS TO GO OUT AND
ENGAGE WITH THE PUBLIC.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE THERE
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
SING THEN ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE JIM E. WHAT WITH A
CALIFORNIA NEWS PUBLISHERS
ASSOCIATION -- I'D LIKE TO TO
SAY AT THE OUTSET THAT
IDEOLOGICALLY SEEIN PAY IS NOT
OPPOSED TO THE USE OF SOCIAL
MEDIA BY ELECTED MEMBERS OF
BROWN ACT BODIES.
BUT BASED ON THE PROPOSAL BUT
IT'S CURRENTLY BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE WE HAVE SOME VERY
SERIOUS CONCERNS ABOUT HOW IT
WOULD OPERATE.
ON THE BROWN ACT WAS PASSED --
BACK IN NINETEEN FIFTY THREE FOR
THE EXPRESS PURPOSE TO GUARANTEE
THAT THE PUBLIC'S BUSINESS --
CONDUCTED BY A LOCAL AGENCY IS
DONE IN AN OPEN AND PUBLIC
MANNER -- AND ONE OF THE KEY
COMPONENTS OF THAT IS TO PROVIDE
NOTICE TO THE PUBLIC OF WHAT IT
IS THAT THE BODY INTENDS. TO DO
WHETHER IT'S A DELIBERATION
WHETHER IT'S DISCUSSION WHETHER
IT'S AN ACTION.
AND SOCIAL MEDIA IN AND OF
ITSELF ONE OF THE KEY
CHARACTERISTICS OF SOCIAL MEDIA --
THAT MAKES IT SUCH A A GLAMOROUS
THING TO USE -- IS ITS
SPONTANEITY A JUST LIKE A
CONVERSATION IN A ROOM WHERE YOU
HAVE NO IDEA WHERE IT'S GOING TO
GO -- WHICH MAKES IT VERY
DIFFICULT FOR BODY TO PROVIDE
THE REQUISITE NOTICE IN THE ACT
RIGHT NOW.
UNFORTUNATELY SB NINE NINETY
DOES NOT ADDRESS THAT ISSUE --
AND IT'S REALLY HARD TO ENVISION --
AT LEAST UNDER THE THE LANGUAGE
NOW.
OUR HOW OF THE USE OF SOCIAL
MEDIA BY A BODY WOULD NOT
VIOLATE THE SERIAL MEETING UP
PROVISION OF THE BROWN ACT WHICH
AGAIN IS A KEY COMPONENT OF THE
BROWN ACT. TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC'S BUSINESS IS DONE OPENLY
AND PUBLICLY. FOR EXAMPLE IF WE
LOOK AT THE DEFINITION OF
DISCUSS AMONGST THEMSELVES THERE
ARE TWO EXCEPTIONS.
TO THAT -- THAT TERM IN THE BILL
ONE IS -- IT WOULD ALLOW
INDIVIDUAL COMMUNICATIONS ARE
MADE POSTED OR SHARED. TO THAT
SO LONG AS THE COMMUNICATIONS BY
A MEMBER OF THE BODY DO NOT
DIRECTLY RESPOND TO ANOTHER
MEMBERS COMMUNICATIONS.
BUT THAT DOES NOT PRECLUDE OF
THIRD PARTY FROM REFERRING TO A
MEMBERS COMMUNICATION -- IN A
SUBSEQUENT SERIES OF
COMMUNICATIONS ARE -- TWEET THAT
REFERENCES OF ONE MEMBERS --
COMMUNICATION BY TWO OTHER
MEMBERS OF A FIVE MEMBER BODY.
WOULD BE A VIOLATION UNDER THE
LAW IN ANY OTHER.
CONTEXT BUT NOT UNDER THE
LANGUAGE IN -- EIGHTY NINE
NINETY TWO SIMILARLY OF THE USE
OF ICONS OR OTHER -- IMHO JEEZ
IF YOU WILL -- TO COMMUNICATE AN
IDEA OR OPINION OR THOUGHT -- IF
ASSUMING AGAIN A FIVE MEMBER
BODY YOU HAVE AN INDIVIDUAL --
MEMBER WHO -- EXPRESSES A FOUGHT
ON A POSITION ON AN ISSUE BEFORE
THE BODY. TO OTHER MEMBERS GIVE
A THUMBS UP.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN DOES THAT
MEAN THAT THEY'RE IN AGREEMENT
HAS CONSENSUS BEEN REACHED THAT
IS TOTALLY UNCLEAR UNDER THE
LANGUAGE IN THE BILL RIGHT NOW?
SO RATHER THAN CLARIFY I THINK
IT RAISES ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS.
THERE IS THE DIGITAL DIVIDE
ISSUE THAT EXIST ARM AND THAT --
IS NOT ONLY THOSE THAT HAVE
ACCESS TO THE INTERNET BUT THERE
MAY BE THOSE THAT HAVE ACCESS TO
THE INTERNET BUT DON'T CHOOSE TO
USE SOCIAL MEDIA.
OUR AS A MEANS OF COMMUNICATION
AND SO THEY WOULD BE.
EXCLUDED FROM THE DEVELOPMENT OF
PUBLIC POLICY OR EVEN THE FORMAL
ACTION OF A POTENTIAL OF VOTE BY
BY A BODY -- HAVING SAID ALL
THAT -- WE RECOGNIZE THAT SOCIAL
MEDIA IS AN EFFECTIVE TOOL FOR
CONSTITUENTS TO USE TO
COMMUNICATE WITH THE ELECTED
MEMBERS OF THEIR BODY -- AND WE
WILL STAND READY WILLING AND
ABLE TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
DISCUSSIONS AND THE DEVELOPMENT
OF GOOD SOCIAL MEDIA POLICY --
AS IT MOVES FORWARD -- WE HAVE
HAD THOSE DISCUSSIONS WITH THE
LEAGUE WITH THE SPECIAL
DISTRICTS -- UNFORTUNATELY THE
BILL AS IT'S WRITTEN NOW --
DOESN'T GET US THERE QUITE YET --
AND IF THE COMMITTEE DOES DECIDE
TO MOVE THE BILL ON OR DECIDES
NOT TO MOVE THE BILL ON NONE THE
LESS WE STAND READY WILLING AND
ABLE TO PARTICIPATE IN THOSE
DISCUSSIONS BUT AS OF NOW --
WE'RE ASKING FOR NO LOOK.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF THE
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE OTHER ANY QUESTIONS
THE COMMITTEE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WARNER ARE.
FOR I MAY GET A RIGHT ONE DAY
SUCH AS THE BATES HOSSA OR TBH.
TBH WORKS -- I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR IN THE LEAGUE FOR THIS I
REMEMBER WHEN I WAS SWORN IN AND
IN MY NEW COUNCILMEMBER TRAINING
TWENTY SIXTEEN WITH THE LEAGUE
OF CITIES.
I WAS SHOCKED TO LEARN THAT IF
ME AND TO MY COLLEAGUES ALL
INCIDENTLY LIKE THE SAME.
ARTICLE ON FACEBOOK THAT THAT
COULD HAVE BEEN CONSIDERED A
BROWN ACT VIOLATION AND YOU KNOW
SINCE THE PURVIEW OF LOCAL
COUNCIL MEMBERS ARE PRIDE FROM
ANYTHING FROM BIKE LANES TO
ROADS TO POT HOLES.
TO PEOPLE SHARING THEIR CONCERNS
ABOUT SAFETY AND AND AND ARE YOU
KNOW OUR COMMUNITY -- I WAS
SHOCKED AND SO I SEE THIS BILL I
THINK IT'S A GOOD MOVE AND
CLARIFICATION A MUCH NEEDED MOVE
IN CLARIFICATION.
OF WHAT'S ALLOWED WHAT'S NOT
ALLOWED I REMEMBER I ONCE WENT
AFTER HAVE THAT TRAINING VERY
GOOD TRAINING -- I WENT THROUGH
AND SCROLL THROUGH THREE HUNDRED
LIKES TO SEE IF ANY OF MY OTHER
COUNCIL MEMBERS SELECTED BECAUSE
I OF COURSE I DIDN'T WANT TO
VIOLATE THE PRODUCT.
AND IN THE END YOU KNOW AND WHEN
YOU HAVE SMALLER COMMUNITIES MY
CITY WAS ONLY SIXTY TWO THOUSAND
PEOPLE -- YOU KNOW IT THAT WOULD
BE AND AND STILL NOTHING THAT
WOULD CAUSE A LOT OF RECORDS FOR
FOR NO REAL INTENT OF
ESTABLISHING -- AN ACTUAL POLICY
POSITION OR HAVING AND AND AND
MEETING AND SO I THINK THIS IS A
REALLY IMPORTANT -- BILL AND I
REALLY APPRECIATE YOU -- AND THE
LEAGUE FOR BRING IT FOR AND HOW
THAT CLARIFICATION I THINK I
LOVE LOCAL JURISDICTIONS AN
ELECTED SCHOOL NEED THANK YOU.
SEVEN RIVER ROBERT RIVAS.
SO I I COMMEND THE AUTHOR OVER
FOR TACKLING THIS ISSUE YOU KNOW
I THINK THAT -- CERTAINLY
ATTENDING TO DRAW ALSO CO LINES
OF COMPLIANCE IS A GOOD THING
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT SOCIAL MEDIA
I THINK YOU KNOW AS AS AS A SAY
YOU KNOW AS WAS STATED.
SOCIAL MEDIA IS A YOU KNOW A
VEHICLE WHERE MOST OF US GET OUR
NEWS AND CERTAINLY STAY
CONNECTED WITH ONE ANOTHER AND I
REPRESENT A DISTRICT THAT HAS A
LOT OF SMALLER JURISDICTIONS AND
CITIES.
IN THE ISSUES I HAVE IS IN YOU
KNOW I THINK WHAT I'M LOOKING AT
THE LEGISLATION IS.
PROVIDE SOME CLARITY AS FAR AS
THE INTERACTIONS AMONGST THE
ELECTED OFFICIALS THEMSELVES
BECAUSE WHAT I SEE IS.
THESE COUNCIL MEMBERS ARE
SUPERVISORS ENGAGING WITH ONE
ANOTHER AND COMING FROM LOCAL
GOVERNMENT.
KNOWING THAT TO MY COLLEAGUES
ARE TAKING A POSITION ON
SOMETHING [inaudible]
YOU NOW.
SHOWING ME THEIR CARS AND WHERE
THEY STAND ON ISSUES IN MY
OPINION POSES A PROBLEM AND
SOMETIMES EVEN A THIRD WILL JUMP
IN BUT THERE'S SUCH A LACK OF
CLARITY IS SUCH A GRAY AREA WHEN
IT COMES THE BROWN ACT.
ASSISTANT I APPRECIATE
LEGISLATION I THINK THAT IT
NEEDS TO BE STRAIGHTENED A BIT --
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ADDRESS NOT
ALLOWABLE IN INTO THE
COMMUNICATION BETWEEN ELECTED
OFFICIALS BUT AS FAR AS THEM
USING THIS AS A VEHICLE.
TO ENGAGE THEIR CITIZENS THE
CONSTITUENCIES I THINK IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT AND SO ANYWAY THAT WE
CAN STRENGTHEN OUR ABILITY. TO
TO CLARIFY -- OUR ABILITY TO USE
IT AND LOCAL OFFICIALS THESE IT
I THINK IS A VERY POSITIVE STEP.
FOR A SIMILAR SO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RENEWS REAVIS.
THANK YOU -- YOU KNOW PRIOR TO
BEING ELECTED -- TO THE ASSEMBLY
I SERVED ON THE COMMISSION THAT
WAS GOVERNED BY -- THE BROWN ACT
AND DEFINITELY.
I'M AWARE OF A LOT OF THE ISSUES
YOU KNOW RELATED TO THIS BUT
AFTER HEARING OPPOSITION ONE OF
THE ISSUES THAT.
MAY BE AND CLEAR IS WHAT THE
DEFINITION OF A DISCUSSION IS
RIGHT LIKE -- WHAT -- THE THE
OPPOSITION WAS SAYING WAS WHERE
THERE IS YOU KNOW LIKE THE
THUMBS UP.
YOU KNOW I ENVISIONED DISCUSSION
WHERE.
THEIR COMMON TEAM YOU KNOW MAYBE
THREE OUT OF THE FIVE MEMBERS OF
A A BODY ARE COMMON TEEN AND
HAVING A DISCUSSION I I MEAN IT.
I'M CURIOUS IF YOU'VE THOUGHT OF
THAT OR IF -- LIKE IT COULD
POTENTIALLY MAKE IT EVEN GREATER
ON WHAT.
THE DISCUSSION IS YOU KNOW I'M
NOT.
IF IF IT'S NOT DEFINED RIGHT IN
THE BILL.
SO THANK YOU ASSEMBLY WOMAN AND
NOW WE HAVE BEEN GRAPPLING.
WITH THAT DEFINITION AS WELL I
JUST WANTED.
TO TO MENTION.
THAT WE ARE A SPECIFIED IN THE
BROWN ACT IS APPLICABLE. TO
SOCIAL MEDIA WITH REGARD TO
BUSINESS OF A SPECIFIC NATURE.
IN THE SUBJECT MATTER
JURISDICTION OF THE BODY.
SO -- UNDER A SCENARIO WHERE --
A MEMBER -- OF THE CITY COUNCIL
THE MAYOR WERE TO POST SOMETHING
SPECIFIC ABOUT A OF AN ISSUE A
DEVELOPMENT COMING BEFORE THE
BOARD.
AND THERE WAS A LEVEL OF
INTERACTION LIKES AND SO FORTH.
THERE'S A LACK OF CLARITY ON
WHETHER OR NOT THAT REPRESENTS
CONSENSUS.
BUT UNDER THE LANGUAGE OF THE
BILL AS IT'S CONSTRUCTED.
THOUGHT THAT WOULD BE SOMETHING
OF A SPECIFIC NATURE IN THE
SUBJECT MATTER JURISDICTION OF
THE BODY AND I KNOW ASSEMBLY --
THE OTHER ASSEMBLY MEMBER
REQUESTS -- IS SUBMITTED -- SOME.
LANGUAGE. TO TO MAKETHAT
ABUNDANTLY CLEAR.
AND I AM ABSOLUTELY MORE THAN
HAPPY TO ENGAGE THAT I WANT TO
BRING CLARITY RIGHT NOW THE
STATUS QUO IS UNACCEPTABLE
THERE'S A THERE'S A GREAT DEAL
OF ANXIETY.
AMONG LOCAL OFFICIALS THE I'M
I'M A FORMER CITY COUNCIL MEMBER
MAYOR.
AND IT WAS JUST AS SOCIAL MEDIA
WAS KIND OF GETTING ROLLING --
AND AND WE WERE TIED UP IN KNOTS
A LITTLE BIT SO I HAVE PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE IN THAT REGARD.
AS SOCIAL MEDIA HAS BECOME
UBIQUITOUS THIS REALLY IS AN
ISSUE CONFRONTED.
BY LOCAL OFFICIALS CELL WERE
ATTEMPTING TO BRING CLARITY HEAR.
THE STATUS QUO IS NOT ACCEPTABLE
THIS BILL IS NOT PERFECT I AM
ABSOLUTELY COMMITTED TO WORKING
WITH THE NEWS PAPER PUBLISHERS I
KNOW THE LEAGUE -- AND THE OTHER
LOCAL GOVERNMENT FOLKS ARE AS
WELL THERE IS A SOLUTION IN HERE
TO AT LEAST HAVE A ROAD MAP
GOING FOR THAT BRING SOME.
CERTAINTY TO LOCAL OFFICIALS BUT
ALSO BRINGS THE BROWN ACT INTO
THE DIGITAL ERA AND CALIFORNIA
OUGHT TO BE LEADING ON THIS
ISSUE AS GROUND ZERO FOR MANY OF
THESE TECHNOLOGIES SELL -- THANK
YOU FOR THAT COMMENT AND I
TOTALLY COMMITTED -- TO TO
BRINGING FURTHER FURTHER CLARITY
AS NEEDED HERE.
YEAH THANK YOU I MEAN I LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING THIS
DISCUSSION I'M SURE IT'S
DIFFICULT TO TRY TO ADAPT TO
WHAT. 1-953-220-1920 TWENTY
GREAT -- AND I'M SURE IT'S NOT
EASY TO GET ON THE FIRST TRY BUT
I I LOOK FORWARD -- FOR YOU TO
CONTINUE WORKING ON THIS AND
MAKE IT CLEAR FOR EVERYONE
INVOLVED THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
[inaudible]
YES.
SOME MEMBER ALMOST THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND THERE IS A IT'S
A GREAT TOPIC AND I THINK FOR ME --
HOW MUCH DIALOGUE HAS BEEN DONE
IT LIKE THE COUNTY LEVELS WITH
COUNTY COUNCIL COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AS FAR AS
IMPLEMENTING A POLICY AND
COMPLIANCE WITH THE BROWN ACT?
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL -- BEFORE WE
GET TO THE POINT TO WHERE WE'RE
AT NOW.
YEAH.
I'M I'M HAVING A JOB AND I'M I'M.
LEADERS CITY LIKE A CITIES YEAH
I MEAN WE IT'S SO IT'S SO YOU
KNOW WHAT WHAT WHAT'S BEEN DONE
AS FAR AS AS AS ASSEMBLYMEMBER
HARD ABOUT SAID WE WE ARE WE THE
LEAGUE ITSELF CONDUCTS TRAININGS --
BUT WHAT WHAT WE ALSO MAKE IT
VERY CLEAR THAT WE THAT THE
LEAGUE DOES NOT PROVIDE DIRECTLY --
COUNCIL IN THAT WE UNDER THE
CURRENT PARADIGM WE HAVE TO THEM
PUSH -- THOSE CONVERSATIONS
LOCALLY TO OUR CITY ATTORNEYS
AND SEEK THEIR COUNSEL AND SO
THAT'S REALLY YOU KNOW WHEN.
WHEN COMING UP WITH THIS CONCEPT --
WE IN THE LEAGUE OF CITIES HAS A
BROWN ACT WORKING GROUP
COMPRISED OF CITY ATTORNEY'S
ACROSS CALIFORNIA AND REALLY
WHEN WE WERE DISCUSSING THIS
ISSUE.
IF YOU KNOW WHAT THE SAME CISCO
CITY ATTORNEY SEES A COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT THAT AND YOU KNOW THEN
THE CITY ATTORNEY THAT'S THAT'S
DOWN SOUTH -- AND SO THERE IS
THAT THAT IS PRECISELY WHERE
WITH THE IMPETUS THIS BILL CAME
FROM IS THAT WE COULDN'T COME TO
A CONSENSUS BECAUSE WITH REGARD
TO THE BROWN ACT IT WAS PASSED.
NINETEEN FIFTY THREE WERE YOU
KNOW WERE WERE WARNED IT AND
DON'T YOU KNOW AND ENGAGING AND
AND AND IN THE DIGITAL AGE.
AND SO THAT'S EXACTLY WHY WE
WANTED THIS MEASURE FOR CLARITY
BECAUSE IT IS A STATE WIDE
STATUE THAT WE HAVE TO FOLLOW
BUT THE INTERPRETATIONS VARY
FROM JURISDICTION TO
JURISDICTION.
I THINK PART OF MY OF MY
QUESTION IS YOU KNOW IT'S A
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS THEY'RE THE
ONES THAT ARE GONNA BE IMPACTED
BY.
ANY RULES THAT ARE ADOPTED WITH
THIS BILL MOVES FORWARD.
OR NOT BUT IT'S AT THE LOCAL
JURISDICTION WHERE THAT.
THAT DISCUSSION NEEDS TO BE HELD
IN OPEN FORUM ON WHETHER IT'S AT
THE COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
A CITY COUNCIL BECAUSE THEY'RE
THE ONES THAT ARE GOING TO BE
HELD ACCOUNTABLE TO THAT POLICY
THAT'S THEIRWELL I SAID ON THE
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS WE
HAD A DAT.
THE THE BROWN ACTED IMPLEMENT
NEW POLICIES TO CONTINUE TO
COMPLY WITH THOSE AND WE HAD --
STUDY SESSIONS WE HAD A SERIES
OF OPEN DIALOGUE WITH THE PUBLIC
INVOLVEMENT ALL THOSE DIFFERENT.
AREAS TO HAVE THAT THAT
ENCOURAGEMENT OF THAT POLICY
MOVING FORWARD ULTIMATELY COUNTY
COUNCIL WOULD MOVE FORWARD WE
WRAPPED UP AS A BOARD.
THAT BECOMES PART OF THE THE
ADHERENCE TO THE TO THE POLICY
THAT'S THEIR THIS.
WITHOUT KNOWING THAT THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS HAVE EXHAUSTED ALL
THAT THAT'S THERE AND AND THEIR
PURVIEW TO IMPLEMENT THAT RULE
AND COMPLY WITH THE BROWN ACT
IT'S IN THAT PURVIEW THAT
THEY'RE GOING TO BE FOLLOWING.
BECAUSE WE DON'T FOLLOW THE
BROWN ACT HERE ON THESE DIESIS
SO HAS THE LOCAL JURISDICTION
BUT EXHAUSTED. TO COMPLY ARE TO
COME UP WITH NEW DIFFERENT --
ORDINANCES OR REGULATIONS TO
COMPLY WITH A BROWN AT THE DEAL
WITH THE THE SOCIAL MEDIA ASPECT
YEAH AND I AND I THAT'S THAT'S A
THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION AND I'LL
SAY THAT I I THE THE FEEDBACK
I'VE RECEIVED FROM.
FROM MIKE AT MY CITY COUNCIL
MEMBERS AND AND MY CITY
ATTORNEY'S IS IS THAT THEY HAVE
HAD THOSE CONVERSATIONS AND HAVE
HAVE YOU KNOW TRIED.
TO THE BEST THEY CAN --
INTERPRET WHICH UNDER THE UNDER
THE PROVISIONS OF THE BROWN ACT.
IT IS IT IS THEIR JOB TO
INTERPRET THOSE PROVISIONS TO
ADD TO THAT WERE YOU SEE THE
CONFUSION LYING I MEAN EVEN
WITHIN JURISDICTION WITH AND
GIVE THE COUNTY WHAT YOU KNOW
CITIES WITHIN THE COUNTY THAN
SPECIAL DISTRICTS WITHIN WITHIN
THE CITY OR COUNTY JURISDICTION.
YOU HAVE DIFFERENT JURISDICTIONS
THROUGHOUT THAT COUNTY OPERATING
UNDER DIFFERENT DIFFERENT
COUNCILS BECAUSE EVERY EVERY
ATTORNEY I HAVE A DIFFERENT --
PROTECTION HOW TO FOLLOW FOLLOW --
YOU KNOW THE THE THIS SORT OF
NEW ERA -- VIGIL AGENT SO I I
WOULD SAY THAT THAT -- WE
CERTAINLY YOU KNOW AS AS
PURVEYORS OF LOCAL CONTROL AND
WE WANT EVERYTHING TO BE
HAPPENING LOCALLY IT'S RARE THAT
WE COME TO THE STATE SAYING WE
NEED HELP PROVIDING A SUITE WE
NEED STATEWIDE SOLUTION FOR THIS --
THAT PROVIDES THE GUIDANCE THAT
IT THAT IS NEEDED FOR OUR LOCAL
OFFICIALS BECAUSE YOU KNOW MY MY
GUYS DON'T LIKE SAY THEY NEED
HELP IN THE STATE BUT IN THIS
CASE THEY THEY START THEY THEY
THEY CERTAINLY DO.
I THINK IT THE QUESTION OF THE
SEWING ROOM WALL IN HIS IS MORE
ON EXHAUSTING THE RESOURCE AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL. TO ADOPT A
POLICY THAT'S GOING TO BE.
HAD HERE TO BUY THE THE LOCAL
ELECTED OFFICIALS THAT ARE THERE
AND I'M NOT SURE I'M HEARING
THAT THAT HAS BEEN EXHAUSTED AT
THAT POINT.
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL TO ADOPT
THOSE POLICIES WITH THAT I DO
HAVE SOME CONCERNS ON THE BILL
BUT THANK YOU FOR FOR BRING IT
FORWARD.
BY THAT THERE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS.
IT.
MAY I RESPOND A LITTLE SURE YOU
GIVE ALL THE ORDERS WITH
DISTRICT PERSPECTIVE.
YEAH SO -- SOME OF THE RIVER ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT WE'VE HEARD
FROM MY SPECIAL DISTRICTS IS IS
IS THAT THAT THEY HAVE ADOPTED.
POLICIES AND WHAT'S THE WHAT'S
HAPPENING IS WE'RE HAVING A
POLICY AT ONE DISTRICT IN THAT
POLICIES SIGNIFICANTLY DIFFERENT
THAN THE POLICY THAT IS AT
ANOTHER DISTRICT WHICH IS WHAT
WHAT I BELIEVE THE THE LEASE
CITIES WAS SAYING IS THAT.
THEY'RE THEY HAVE LOOKED AT THIS
THEY HAVE THEIR THEIR COUNCILS
LOOK AT AND THEY'VE ADOPTED
POLICIES FOR THEIR CITY.
AND IN ONE CITY IS VASTLY
DIFFERENT FROM ANOTHER CITY AND
THEY'RE THEY'RE OPERATING UNDER
DIFFERENT RULES BUT THEY'RE
FOLLOWING THE LAW THE FOLLOWING
THE RULES AS THEY INTERPRET IT.
BUT THEIR INTERPRETATION IS SO
DIFFERENT THAT THEY'RE THAT
THEY'RE ASKING FOR THE GUIDANCE
SIMILAR TO WHAT YOU KNOW WHAT
WHAT WE'RE SEEING -- ON THE THE
BACK BAND THROUGH THEIR RIGHT WE
HAD A DIFFERENT JURISDICTION
HAVING DIFFERENT RULES ON ON
WHAT WAS ALLOWED WHAT WASN'T --
AND THE THE GOOD THE THE
INDUSTRY CAME AND SAID HEY LOOK.
WE RATHER JUST HAVE ONE POLICY
SO THAT WE KNOW PROVIDED THE
GUIDES AND THAT'S WHERE WE'REAT
AT THIS POINT WE HAVE POLICIES
AT AT THAT VARYING AGENCIES.
WE'RE LOOKING FOR ONE THE
CLARITY SO THAT WE ACTUALLY HAVE.
YOU KNOW THE SIMILAR POLICY
THROUGHOUT THE STATE BUT ISN'T
THAT THE THE NUCLEUS OF LOCAL
GOVERNMENT TO BE ABLE TO
DISAGREE OR HAVE DIFFERENT
POLICIES ON DIFFERENT THINGS HOW
THEY'RE IMPLEMENTING A COMPLYING
WITH LAW.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE YES SOME
OF ROOM YEAH -- LIKE TO WEIGH IN
ON THIS TOO I I I I CERTAINLY
THINK THERE'S ALWAYS A GOOD
ARGUMENT TO BE MADE FOR LOCAL
CONTROL -- BUT THERE'S ALSO I
THINK A REALLY IMPORTANT
ARGUMENT TO BE MADE HERE FOR
UNIFORMITY IN IN OUR LAWS THE
THE BROWN ACT AS A STATE LAW.
THAT APPLIES EQUALLY TO ALL
JURISDICTIONS AND THE BETTER THE
UNIFORMITY OF UNDERSTANDING OF
THAT LAW IS AND THE MORE EVENLY
IT'S APPLIED.
THEN THE EASIER IT IS FOR
INDIVIDUAL COUNCIL MEMBERS -- TO
KNOW WHAT'S RIGHT AND WRONG IT'S
TIME YOU KNOW YOU AND YOUR
AGENCIES IN THE LEAGUE OF CITIES --
TEACH OF LOCAL GOVERNMENT
OFFICIALS -- IT WOULD BE IF IT
MAKES IT HARDER IN MY VIEW --
FOR A OF LOCAL GOVERNMENT
MEMBERS TO TO DO THEIR JOBS AND
UNDERSTAND THAT IN DOING THEIR
JOB.
THERE ARE OF THEY'RE NOT
VIOLATING THE LOT NOBODY.
I HOPE WANTS TO KNOWINGLY
VIOLATE LAWS LIKE THIS -- AND
HAVING AN UNDERSTANDING OF THEM
IS IS CRITICAL ESPECIALLY IN A
INCREASINGLY COMPLICATED WORLD
THAT WE COMMUNICATE AND SO I I
DO THINK THERE'S WORK TO BE DONE
ON THIS BILL BUT I I THINK IT'S
WORTHY OF MOVING FORWARD.
SO THAT WE CAN TRY TO IT AT
ACHIEVE THAT -- THAT GOAL OF
HAVING A UNIFORM UNDERSTANDING
OF WHAT THE LAW IS.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BURNER OR BAR
THANK YOU I MOVE THE BILL.
WE HAVE A MOTION.
AND WE HAVE A SECOND.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR -- I JUST
WANT -- TO TRIED TO ASSURE HER
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS -- DAD
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT LOCAL
OFFICIALS ARE ASKING -- FOR BY
ITS VERY NATURE OF BROWN ACT IS
STATEWIDE POLICY THEY ARE ASKING
FOR A STATEWIDE -- INTERVENTION
SO TO SPEAK ON THIS -- I'M NOT
PRESENTING A FINISHED PRODUCT TO
YOU.
UP MY HESITATION IS IF IF WE PUT
THIS UP FOR A VOTE WE WIND UP
ONE VOTE SHORT.
ESSENTIALLY THIS CONVERSATION IS
DEAD FOR THE YEAR.
AND WHAT I WOULD SAY IS THAT WE
ARE VERY CLOSE AT LEAST IN MY
MIND WERE CLOSE TO GETTING
SOMETHING THAT'S WORKABLE.
WITH A FULL COMMITMENT TO SIT
WITH THE NEWSPAPER PUBLISHERS
AND WORK THROUGH SOME OF THOSE
ISSUES I THINK UNDERLYING THIS
IS AN ACKNOWLEDGEMENT THAT --
YOU KNOW BY ITS VERY NATURE
SOCIAL MEDIA INTERACTIONS ARE
PUBLIC ONES.
AND WE WANT TO FACILITATE --
OPEN COMMUNICATION WITH THE
PUBLIC AND THE IN MY WAY OF
THINKING THIS IS IN FURTHERANCE
OF THE GOALS OF THE BROWN ACT
WITH REGARD TO OPEN GOVERNMENT.
IT TO SPECIFICALLY TO YOUR
QUESTION AROUND HAVE WE
EXHAUSTED ALL LOCAL APPROACHES --
I I GUESS OF A PLANNED WORDS I
THINK LOCAL OFFICIALS ARE
EXHAUSTED AT TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT HOW TO COMPLY WITH THIS.
SO IT'S OUR RESPONSIBILITY I
BELIEVE TO PROVIDE A STATEWIDE
APPROACH THAT GIVES SOME
CERTAINTY TO LOCAL OFFICIALS SO --
I WOULD LOVE TO GET IT THROUGH --
THIS COMMITTEE TODAY WITH THE
ASSURANCE THAT -- I WILL ENGAGE
WITH ALL INTERESTED PARTIES
YOURSELF INCLUDED MISTER RAMOS.
OUGHT TO TO ADDRESS ANY
OUTSTANDING CONCERNS AND SIT
WITH OPPOSITION I REALLY HAMMER
OUT.
A WORKABLE -- PLAN GOING FORWARD
FOR FOR OUR LOCAL OFFICIALS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA YOU HAVE
MY COMMITMENT ON THAT.
AND WITH THAT MADAM CHAIR -- I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NAY VOTES
WE CAN BRING THE BROWN ACT INTO
THE DIGITAL AGE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- YOU KNOW
I'M SITTING HERE LISTENING TO
BOTH SIDES OF THIS AND I HAVE SO
MANY THOUGHTS -- YES AS A LOCAL
OFFICIAL WE HAVE.
GUIDELINES IN THE BROWN ACT WAS
THERE TO PROTECT OUR
CONSTITUENTS.
AND I THINK THAT'S A PIECE THE
WERE MISSING WERE HAVING THIS
CONVERSATION -- QUITE FRANKLY IT
FUNDAMENTALLY I'M NOT WITH YOU
ON THIS TODAY AND I WISH I WAS
I'M REALLY CONCERNED ABOUT.
MAKING SURE THAT EVERYBODY HAS
ACCESS OR HAS -- THE REMOTE TO
BE TRUTHFUL AND HONEST TO OUR
CONSTITUENTS I MEAN THE BROWN
ACTS THERE FOR A REASON RIGHT.
AND I JUST THINK FUNDAMENTALLY
THAT THIS IS NOT READY AT ALL --
BUT I THINK THAT NEXT YEAR LET'S
WORK ON IT AND I'LL BE MORE THAN
HAPPY TO HELP OUT -- SO THAT'LL
BE VOTING NO TODAY.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY NO LACKEY.
LACKEY NOT VOTING BLOOM.
BLOOM I BRING HER OF THAT.
BOERNER HORVATH I RAMOS.
RAMOS SNOW THREE OF US.
THREE OF US SIRE ROBERT REAVIS.
ROBERT RIVERSIDE VOEPEL
[inaudible]
NO [inaudible] FORTY THREE
THAT'S A WE'RE NOT MISSING
ANYONE.
VOTING YES ARE I APOLOGIZE
[inaudible]
BUT THERE.
DO YOU WITHOUT OBJECTION WOULD
YOU LIKE RECONSIDERATION.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
RECONSIDERATION [inaudible]
TWENTY TWENTY WE NEED.
IS THAT SOMEONE EVER CALL RUN
AWAY.
OKAY THANK YOU -- YEAH.
ITEM NUMBER TWO AB SEVEN OF
SEVEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA
.
THANK THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS AB SEVEN OH SEVEN
INCREASES VALUE WATERS COST
THRESHOLD ABOVE WHICH A FORMAL
BIDDING PROCESS REQUIRED.
250-002-50000 DOLLARS AND
AUTHORIZES THE AGENCIES ELECTED
BOARD INCREASE THE THRESHOLD BY
2% PER YEAR BY ACTION ADOPTED AN
OPEN PUBLIC MEETING TO KEEP UP
WITH INFLATION.
DALY WATERS FORMAL BIDDING
THRESHOLD WAS LAST UPDATED BY SB
EIGHTEEN SIXTY IN NINETEEN
NINETY EIGHT MORE THAN TWENTY
YEARS AGO.
SINCE THAT TIME INFLATION AS A
BLOW TO THE PURCHASING POWER OF
THE TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLAR
THRESHOLD TO THE EXTENT THAT
EVEN SIMPLE PROJECTS.
SUCH AS ERECTING A FENCE ARE
STILL INSTALLING A WAREHOUSE
GARAGE DOOR.
REQUIRES A FORMAL BIDDING
PROCESS WHICH CAN COST MORE THAN
THE ACTUAL PROJECT.
AB SEVEN OH SEVEN WOULD ALLOW
THE SMALL PROJECTS TO BE SUBJECT
TO AN INFORMAL BIDDING PROCESS
IN WHICH QUOTES ARE SOLICITED
FROM KNOWN RESPONSIBLE
CONTRACTORS.
AND THE PROJECTS ARE AWARDED TO
THE ONE MOST SUITED TO DO THE
WORK.
INFORMAL BUT IS NOT ONLY LESS
COSTLY SAVING SCARES REPAIR AND
TAX DOLLARS IT IS ALSO LESS TIME
CONSUMING.
THESE MINOR PUBLIC WORKS
PROJECTS CAN HAVE A BIG IMPACT
ON PUBLIC SAFETY BY AFFECTING
WATER SUPPLY AND FLOOD CONTROL
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR THE TWO
MILLION PEOPLE IT SUPPLIES.
MANY PUBLIC AGENCIES ALREADY
HAVE HIGHER FORMAL BIDDING
THRESHOLDS JUST LAST YEAR AB
TWENTY ONE THIRTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MAYES INCREASED
COMPETITIVE BIDDING THRESHOLD OF
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR EVERY
PARK AN OPEN SPACE DISTRICT IN
THE STATE.
ALLOWS THE GOVERNING BOARD TO
INCREASE THE THRESHOLD BUT 2%
PER YEAR.
INFORMAL BIDDING IS ALSO MORE
WORKABLE FOR WOMEN AND MINORITY
OWNED BUSINESSES WHICH ARE OFTEN
SMALLER COMPANIES THAT LACK THE
STAFF RESOURCES TO PURSUE
PROJECTS TO THE FORMAL BIDDING
PROCESS.
THEY NEED ONLY REGISTER WITH THE
STATE DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS COMPLY WITH PREVAILING
WAGE LAW AND SUBMIT AN INFORMAL
BIT.
IN RESPONSE THE OPPOSITION'S
REQUEST THAT VALUE WATER JOIN
CUT CASA DEL WATER.
HAS EXPLORED THIS OPTION WITH
KAFKA.
DID DELAYS IN PROCEDURES
ADDITIONAL ACCOUNTING PROCEDURES
AND SHIFTING FROM ELECTED BOARD
AN APPOINTED BOARD.
DIE WATER CONCLUDED THAT CUT
BECAUSE OF THE RIGHT CHOICE --
NOT ADDRESS THE ISSUES RAISED BY
THIS BILL.
IT IS WORTH NOTING THE COUPLE
HAS A TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLAR THRESHOLD FOR FORMAL
BILLET BIDDING.
AND AB SO SEVEN OH SEVEN ONLY
RESPECT AYE WATERS.
FIFTY THOUSAND I APPRECIATE WANT
TO THANK THE OPPOSITION FOR
BRINGING THEIR CONCERNS TO ME
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
TO HAVE PRODUCTIVE CONVERSATIONS
WITH THEM -- AS LONG WITH THE
SPONSORS THE BILL MOVES FORWARD.
WITH THE PROVIDE SUPPORTING
TESTIMONIES RACHEL GIPSON SANTA
CLARA VALLEY WATER DISTRICT AND
REGIONAL SLOWLY WITH THE
MINORITY BUSINESS CONSORTIUM.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS RACHEL
GIPSON VICTOR GOVERNOR FAIRS FOR
THE SANTA CLARA VALLEY WATER
DISTRICT KNOWN AS VALLEY WATER
WE'RE SPECIAL DISTRICT AS THE
WATER SUPPLY FLOOD PROTECTION
AND IT BERMAN OF STEWARDSHIP.
AGENCY FOR THE TWO MILLION
PEOPLE OF SANTA CLARA COUNTY
THOUSANDS OF SILICON VALLEY JOB
PRETTY BUSY BUSINESSES EIGHTY
SEVEN OH SEVEN SIMPLY ALLOWS OUR
THRESHOLD FOR FORMAL BIG
CONTRACTING KEEP UP WITH
INFLATION OF 2% PER YEAR.
AND SET THE THRESHOLD TO THE
SAME LITTLE AFFORDED TO EVERY
PARK IN OPEN SPACE DISTRICT IN
THE STATE.
OVER TIME OF COURSE INFLATION
HAS REDUCE THAT VALUE FOR PAROLE
BID THRESHOLD SUCH THAT MINOR
PROJECTS FOR A FULL BLOWN SEALED
BID PROCESS COMPLETE WITH AND
YOUR DRAWINGS PLAN SPECS FROM
PRESENTATIONS ETCETERA COSTING
FAR MORE THAN THE PROJECT ITSELF.
VALLEY WATER SHOULD BE ABLE TO
USE THE INFORMAL BID PROCESS FOR
MINOR PUBLIC WORKS REQUIRED BY
OUR ELECTED BOARD OF DIRECTORS.
THAT POLICY REQUIRES MULTIPLE
BIDS FROM RESPONSIBLE BIDDERS
AND THE LOWEST RESPONSIVE BIDDER
IS AWARDED THE JOB.
IT ALSO MAKES IT EASIER FOR
SMALL BUSINESSES INCLUDING WOMEN
AND MINORITY OWNED BUSINESSES.
TODAY YOU'LL HEAR FROM THE
OPPOSITION ARE CONTRACTING
THRESHOLD SHOULD REMAIN FROZEN
AT THE NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT
LEVEL IT PROJECT CURRENTLY REST
UNTIL ITS PURCHASING POWER IS SO
ERODED BY INFLATION WE HAVE NO
CHOICE BUT TO PARTICIPATE IN CUT
CUT.
WELL THAT STATUE GIVES LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS THE OPTION YOU THE
HIGHER BIDDING PERSONAL ALSO
RECORDS IN PERSON BY STATE
APPOINTED COMMISSION REQUIRED TO
MEET ONLY ONCE PER YEAR.
WE REVIEWED KAFKA AND WE DO HAVE
SERIOUS CONCERNS OUR WATER
SUPPLY AND FLOOD PROTECTION
PRODUCTS OFTEN REQUIRE WORK TO
BE COMPLETED WITHIN A VERY SHORT
PERMIT WINDOW.
SOMETIMES A SHORT AS A FEW WEEKS
TO ACCOMMODATE NESTING BIRDS
MIGRATING FISH AND OTHER
SENSITIVE SPECIES IF THERE WERE
PROCESS APPEAL WE'RE VERY
CONCERNED THE STATE APPOINTED
COMMISSION WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO
PROPERLY INVESTIGATED AND CAN BE
SPECIAL MEETINGS TO JUDICATA.
IN TIME FOR FLOOD CONTROL
COMPANY TO BE COMPLETED WITHIN
THAT NARROW PERMIT WINDOW.
BUT I ASSURE YOU ARE ELECTED
BOARD OF DIRECTORS WHAT IN ORDER
TO PREVENT THE LIFE SAFETY RISK.
TO OUR COMMUNITIES DURING THE
COMING RAINY SEASONS WHILE
VALLEY WATERS OPEN RECONSIDERING
PARTICIPATION CUP IN THE FUTURE
OUR AGENCY HAS DETERMINED THAT
CONVERTING TO IT.
RIGHT NOW WOULD NOT APPROVE
FINANCIAL MANAGEMENT AND MAY
DELAY LIKE SAFETY PROJECTS WHEN
LEGISLATURE ENACTED CUT GOOD
GIVE LOCAL JURISDICTIONS THE
OPTIONS WHICH OPTION TO CHOOSE
TO PARTICIPATE.
IT DID NOT INTENDED OTHER
CONTRACTING MECHANISMS BE FROZEN
UNTIL INFLATION FORCES EVERY
JURISDICTION IN A CUP CUP.
AGENCIES NEED THE OPTION TO
CHOOSE THE CONTRACTING TOOL IN
OUR TOOLBOX THAT'S BEST FOR
THEIR CIRCUMSTANCES.
MANAGER MEMBERS I URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT EIGHTY SEVEN OH SEVEN TO
ENSURE THE EFFICIENT EFFECTIVE
LOCALLY CONTROLLED CONTRACTING
CONTINUES TO SERVE THE WATER
SUPPLY FLOOD PROTECTION
ENVIRONMENTAL STEWARDSHIP NEEDS
OF SILICON VALLEY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHERS IN
SUPPORT IF COM MY NAME IS
REGINALD SWILLY I'M A FOUNDER
AND OF PRINCIPLE THAT MINORITY
BUSINESS CONSORTIUM.
AND MY NOTED BUSY BUSINESS
EXPLORES CONSORTIUM EXIST TO
HELP WOMEN AND MINORITY
CONTRACTORS PREVIOUSLY ON ENGAGE
BUSINESS COMMUNITIES HAVE ACCESS.
TO CONTRACT IMPOSSIBILITIES IN
MAJOR CONT -- CONSTRUCTION
PROJECTS AND PROCUREMENT OF THE
PROCUREMENT PROCESS IS -- WE ARE
WORKING WITH THE VALUE WATER --
SANTA CLARA VALLEY WATER
DISTRICT BECAUSE WE ARE TALKING
WITH THEM ABOUT OPENING UP THIS
PROCESS SO OTHER CONTRACTORS CAN
BE AVAILABLE WE HAVE VERY A
BIFURCATED.
CONTRACTING WORLD THAT WE LIVE
HERE AND THIS BIFURCATED AWAY
WHERE THEY'RE A BIG COMPANIES
THAT GET THEIR ANYTHING THAT WE
HAVE NO INFRASTRUCTURE FOR NEW
COMPANIES GUYS COMING OUT OF
COLLEGE -- OR LABORERS THAT WANT
TO START THEIR OWN BUSINESS NOW
I NOTICED THAT -- A A GROUP OF
LABORERS ARE.
OPPOSING THIS WE KNOW WE HAVE.
OF A PARTICULAR.
BUSINESS CLIMATE NOW FOR PEOPLE
ALL SUBSERVIENT TO THE LARGER
COMPANIES BECAUSE THEY CAN NEVER
BREAK OUT.
BECAUSE IT'S DIFFICULT TO START
A NEW BUSINESS BECAUSE THEY
DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO ALL THESE
CONTRACTS THAT THAT THESE MAJOR
COMPANIES ARE GETTING FROM IT WE
ARE A MINORITY BUSINESS
CONSORTIUM HAD A CONTRACT WITH
THE FORTY NINES NEW STADIUM.
AND WE HELP MOVE FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS FROM COMPANIES WHO WOULD
HAVE WATER NEARLY HAD THOSE
CONTRACTS TO NEW CONTRACTORS NO
WE THINK THAT THE THE TECH
INDUSTRY IS BOOMING WITH
INNOVATION.
SIMPLY BECAUSE IT'S WIDE OPEN
AND AND WE FEEL THAT BECOMES THE
WHOLE CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY HAVE
CLAMPED DOWN ON THIS ON THIS
INDUSTRY SO THAT WE CAN GET NEW
COMPANIES AND WE CAN'T GET NEW
INNOVATION WE CAN'T GET GUYS
COMING OUT A CUP COMING OUT OF
COLLEGE.
THAT CAN COME INTO A PROCESS
WHERE THEY CAN GET EASILY EASY
CONTRACTS LIKE THIS SO THAT THEY
COULD BUILD THE COMPANY FROM
NOTHING TO SOMETHING.
AND WE HAVE MANY OMPANIES STUCK
IN.
VERY SMALL -- POOL OF WE HAVE A
REALLY SMALL CONTRACTS AND WE
THINK THAT WHAT THE WATER
DISTRICT IS TRYING TO DO IS OPEN
IT UP EVEN MORE AND I'LL
CONVERSATIONS WITH THEM.
I REALLY THINK THE FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLAR LIMIT IS REALLY
WEAK RIGHT.
BUT I THINK IT IS THE LEAST THAT
YOU CAN DO AT SOUTH STATE
LEGISLATORS WE DON'T KNOW HOW TO
DO WITH CAPITALISM THE WAY IT IS
RIGHT NOW.
BECAUSE ANY BIG ELECTRICAL
COMPANY IS NOT GOING TO LET ME
START ELECTRICAL COMPANY AND
COMPETE AGAINST THEM.
AND CAPITALISM SAY HIS POWER CAN
AFFECT YOU MORE THAN MOUNTAINS
THAT THAT THEN MY GOOD ORK AND
MY INNOVATION AND MY INNOVATION
WILL DIE ON THE VINE.
AND I THINK US IN HIS WORK WITH
LABOR AND I HAVE WORKED WITH HIM
OVER AND OVER -- FOR MANY YEARS
NOW AND HIS WORK WITH US TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT HOW WE CAN OPEN
THESE AT THE THE PROCESS OF FOUR
WOMEN AND MINORITY BUSINESS FOR
VETERAN BUSINESS WITH THIS
ADVANTAGE ABOUT VITAMIN
BUSINESSES. FOR THE LGBT OF
BUSINESS COMMUNITY THERE ARE
BUSINESS COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
REALLY OUTSIDE OF THE OF THOSE --
HOLE CONTRACTING POOL HERE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IT
EXISTS EVERYWHERE IN EVERY
COUNTY AND IN THIS WHOLE STATE
WE THINK THAT DO YOU.
BY GOING IN THIS DIRECTION WE'LL
BE MAKING A SMALL STEP THAT
WOULD ENCOURAGE US THAT AS WE
TRY TO DEVELOP SOME OF THE SMALL
BUSINESSES THAT WE TRY TO BRING
ACCESS TO THEM.
THAT THIS WILL BE SOMETHING THAT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS
MOVING FORWARD.
WE SUPPORT THIS WE THINK THIS --
AND WE SUPPORT IT WHOLEHEARTEDLY
BUT WE THINK IT'S REALLY SMALL.
AND IF YOU COULD BUILD IN A WAY
FOR TODAY BY.
I THINK I GOT IT.
OTHERS IN US SUPPORT.
AND I'LL BUT RATHER WITH CREW
STRATEGIES ON BEHALF OF THE CITY
OF SAN JOSE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THE NO BLESSED HAD WITH
CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL UTILITIES
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
BROWN'S ROSS THROUGH THE
CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION SUPPORT THANK YOU.
JOSH A HUG WITH THE MID
PENINSULA REGIONAL OPEN SPACE
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT THANK YOU --
MICHAEL RATIGAN ON BEHALF OF THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS SANTA CLARA
COUNTY IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE OF THOSE IN
OPPOSITION [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS ANY
BERNACCHI ON BEHALF OF THE
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY FORCE
ACCOUNT COUNCIL -- STEVE FAQ IS
A COALITION OF PUBLIC WORKS
CONTRACTORS.
AND CONSTRUCTION UNIONS -- THAT
HAVE COME TOGETHER -- FOR OVER
THIRTY YEARS TO PROTECT AND
PROMOTE -- THE BENEFITS AND THE
USE OF THE PUBLIC CONTRACT CODE --
WE ACTUALLY LOOK AT THIS BILL
VERY DIFFERENTLY THAN THE
WITNESS WITH THE MINORITY
BUSINESS GROUPS -- WE BELIEVE
THIS BILL HAS WRITTEN IN MAY NOT
BE THE INTENT OF THE AUTHOR --
AND WE'RE HAVING VERY DEEP
DISCUSSIONS WITH THEM BUT AS A
WRITTEN THIS BILL WOULD GREATLY
DIMINISH THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
SMALL BUSINESSES AND MINORITY
CONTRACTORS IN THE STATE -- THE
LEGISLATURE SUCH KIND THE CRUX
OF OUR OUR OF OUR OPPOSITION IS
THAT.
THE THE STRUCTURE OF THE BILL AS
WE READ IT -- SEVERELY
DIMINISHES OPPORTUNITIES FOR
PUBLIC WORKS CONTRACTORS TO BID
ON PROJECTS -- FROM THE DISTRICT --
THE LEGISLATURE ALSO ADDRESSED
THIS ISSUE GLOBALLY WHEN IT
CREATED THE UNIFORM PUBLIC
CONSTRUCTION COST ACCOUNTING ACT --
WHEN THEY CREATED THAT ACT THE
LEGISLATURE WAS ATTEMPTING TO
STOP CONSTERNATION IN THE
LEGISLATURE -- ON THESE FORCE
ACCOUNT ISSUES AND WHAT THEY DID
IS THEY CREATED A PROVISION OF
LAW THAT WOUD ALLOW PUBLIC
AGENCIES TO OPT IN ON A
VOLUNTARY BASIS BY ORDINANCE OF
THEIR LOW -- OPERATING BOARDS.
AND HAVE A MUCH GREATER -- A
MUCH GREATER -- FLEXIBILITY FOR
IT NOT ONLY BIT THRESHOLDS BUT
FOR WORK THEY COULD DO IN HOUSE.
AND ALSO INFORMAL BID.
THE REQUESTED BY THE DISTRICT
THAT IS BEING A PLACE IN THIS --
THIS BILL IS LESS THAN WHAT
WOULD BE PROVIDED TO THEM IF
THEY OPTED INTO THE ACT OVER
TWELVE HUNDRED AGENCIES IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAVE PTED
IN TO YOU FROM PUBLIC
DESTRUCTION COST ACCOUNTING ACT.
THEY THE HAVE -- I BELIEVE IF
YOU WOULD POOR TO REACH OUT TO
ANY ONE OF THEM THEY WOULD ALL
SEEING THE BENEFITS AND IT.
PROBABLY EDUCATE YOU ON HOW NOT
COMPLICATED IT HAS TO OPERATE
WITHIN THE ACTING USE THE ACT --
THAT BEING SAID.
WE HAVE BEEN WORKING VERY
CLOSELY WITH THE AUTHOR -- TO
ADDRESS OUR CONCERNS I THINK --
HE IS VERY AWARE OF OF WHERE
WE'RE AT ON THIS -- WE WOULD
LIKE TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
HIM TO GET CLARITY ON WHAT WORK
CONCERNED WITH AND WHAT HE'S
TRYING TO ACHIEVE WITH THE BILL --
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THEM HOW WE CAN GET A GOOD
PLACE BUT UNFORTUNATELY THE
DAVIS RESPECTIVELY OPPOSED TO
THIS BILL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR TIM CRIMMINS --
INTERNATION OF OPERATING VENEERS --
WITH GREAT DIFFERENCE TO OUR
LABOR CHAIR ALSO -- WILL KICK IN
OPPOSITION AS A BILL IS IN PRINT --
AND AS MR BUT NOT SHE STATED WE
ARE WORRIED ABOUT PRESIDENT HERE
BREAKING AWAY FROM C. FACT.
WHICH IS UNIFORM COST COUNTY
COMMISSION THAT WAS A GRAND
COMPROMISE -- BETWEEN SEVERAL
PARTIES IN THE EARLY EIGHTIES --
DIXIE MAY BE THE ONLY ONE I
REMEMBER SET HERE FEE SUCH --
BUT IT WAS IT WAS A GRAND
COMPROMISE OF THE WORDING
AGENCIES BUT PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
SECTOR UNIONS ALSO.
IN THAT AGAIN THAT THAT
COMMISSION WE WE'VE YOU IS VERY
IMPORTANT IT ESTABLISHES UNIFORM
COSCON PROCEDURES SO WE KNOW
EVERYONE'S OPERATING ON THE SAME
LEVEL.
AND EVERYONE HAS.
THE ROOTS THE INDIVIDUAL
SCRUTINY AND AND AND SAME LEVEL
OF WORK WE CAN ALL ACHIEVE BUT
AGAIN AND FORTY AS A BILL IS IN
PRINT -- WE DO APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR TRYING TO WORK WITH US
BUT UNFORTUNATELY WE HAVE WE ARE
UNABLE TO GET THERE AND STILL IN
OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS KATONA HIT
AROUND THE CALIFORNIA STATE
COUNCIL FLAVORS WERE ALSO
OPPOSED THE REASONS ALREADY
STATED WE HAVE BEEN WORKING
CLOSELY WITH THE AUTHOR WE ARE
OPPOSED THE BILL AS IT IS
CURRENTLY IN PRINT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS.
ON NO QUESTIONS ENTERTAIN A
MOTION [inaudible]
THE MOTION.
WHERE MOTION A SECOND WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE?
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS AND I DO APPRECIATE
THE COMMENTS OF THE OPPOSITION
AND WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THEM I THINK THERE'S
AN OPPORTUNITY HERE WILL BE CAN
MEET THE NEEDS OF BOTH THE
SPONSOR.
AND THE OPPOSITION AND
COMMITMENT TO MY BEST EFFORT TO
GET THERE.
OF A SUMMER KALRA -- WHAT I
HEARD?
RIGHT HERE.
IS THAT YOU ARE WILLING TO WORK
WITH THE LABOR ON THIS AND TRY
TO FIND TO IT.
SO I'LL SUPPORT YOUR BILL
BECAUSE I DO KNOW THAT YOU WILL
DO WHATEVER YOU CAN TO WORK WITH
LABOR SO I HOPE YOU GUYS CAN
IRON THAT OUT SOONER THAN LATER --
AND I APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING
THIS FORWARD FOR YOUR DISTRICT I
UNDERSTAND THE IMPORTANCE OF OUR
DISTRICT BILLS.
WITH THAT'LL BE SUPPORTING YOUR
BILL TODAY THANK YOU.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AGUIAR-CURRY [inaudible]
LACKEY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I LACKEY YOU BLOOM.
BLOOMAYE BURNER HER BATH FROM
MOST.
THOMAS AYE THREE OF US ROBERT
RIVAS.
ROBERT RIVAS SIDE VOEPEL.
VOEPEL HI.
THE BILLS UP FIVE ZERO WE'RE
GONNA TAKE A QUICK BREAK HERE
AND WE'LL COME BACK [inaudible]
IS. FIVE MINUTES TO THE MAX
[inaudible]
OKAY.
AB FIVE SEVENTY YOU MAY GO THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS AB FIVE
SEVENTY IS A COMPANION MEASURE
TO MY BILL ACA.
ONE THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
INVESTMENT ACT THIS BILL WILL
ONLY BECOME OPERATIVE IF A CA
ONE IS APPROVED BY VOTERS.
BUT IT IS NECESSARY TO CODIFY
IMPLEMENTATION DETAILS AND
CLARIFY TERMS IN A CA ONE THE
MAY NOT.
THAT MAY NOT BELONG IN THE
CONSTITUTION. FOR PURPOSES OF A
CA ONE AB FIVE SEVENTY DEFINES
AFFORDABLE HOUSING TO
ADDITIONALLY INCLUDE A FIRST
TIME HOME BUYER.
PROGRAM OFFERED BY A LOCAL
AGENCY.
SB FIVE SEVENTY ALSO CLARIFIES
THAT A PARCEL TAX IMPOSED
PURSUANT TO A CA ONE MAY INCLUDE
EXEMPTIONS FOR SENIORS AND
DISABLED PERSONS WHICH IS
CONSISTENT WITH EXILE EXISTING
LAW.
I ASK FOR YOUR IBM.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBER
SERRA FLOCKS CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION WE ARE STRONG
SUPPORTERS OF A CA ONE ALONG
WITH MANY OF OUR AFFILIATES.
THIS IS A COMPANION BILL THAT'S
IMPORTANT TO KEEP MOVING SO WE
ARE SUPPORT THANK YOU.
A MIXTURE MEMBERS -- DAN CARRIED
WITH WITH THE CALIFORNIA CITIES
WE ALSO WERE STRONG SUPPORTERS
OF STRONG SUPPORTERS OF A CA ONE
AND ALSO WOULD LIKE TO SEE THIS
COMPANION BILL A MOVE FORWARD.
FOR THIS REASON WE SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN WAS
THE COMMITTEE GERMANS MATH HERE
BEHALF OF THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL ALSO
IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU OKAY.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES OF SUPPORT
[inaudible]
A POSITION.
SAM NUNN ABOUT -- FROM THE DíAS
MOMENTS.
OKAY HAVE A FIRST AND SECOND.
READY FOR CLOSED -- I THINK THIS
COMPANION BILL IS SOMETHING THAT
WE HAD WE HAVE A VISION OF WHAT
MAY OR MAY NOT HAPPEN AND I
REALLY WOULD ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
TODAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OKAY SIX THREE WILL HALL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AGUIAR-CURRY HI AGUIAR-CURRY I
LACKEY SORRY CAN.
LACKEY NOW BLOOM.
BLOOM I'VE BOERNER HORVATH.
RAMOS.
RAMOS SIDE THREE OF US ROBERT
RIVAS ROBERT RIVAS SIDE VOEPEL
[inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
YEAH.
IT IS.
FOUR ZERO ONE THREE OF US ONE
MORE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WITH OVER BACK.
THANK YOU.
FOR THAT.
SHOULD GET ALONG AS A SHOW UP
[inaudible]
GLORIA.
WE HAVE SOME ADD ONS SO ONE WE
GO AHEAD AND DO THAT SECRETARY.
USING PHONY DOWN ON IT.
SO MISTER LUCKY I THINK WAS YEAH
ITEM ONE AB FIVE SEVENTY
AGUIAR-CURRY -- NOW THAT'S ON
CALL -- A. B. TWO A. B. SEVEN OH
SEVEN KALRA BURNER HER VAST
THREE OF US.
MR LACKEY [inaudible]
LACKEY II.
ITEM -- THREE ITEM FOR ITEM FOR
A BI.
TEN FIFTY THREE AT DAWALY.
LACKEY LIKE LACKEY I FINAL VOTE
ON THAT'S NINE ZERO NINE ZERO I
THE CONSENT CALENDAR LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE.
RAMOS.
RAMESSIDE.
FINAL VOTE ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR IS EIGHT ZERO THAT SON --
ITEMS SIX AB TWELVE OR EIGHTEEN
LACKEY.
LACKEY I FINAL VOTE ON THAT IS.
NINE ZERO ITEM SEVEN A. B.
THIRTEEN OH FOUR WALDRON LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE FINAL VOTE ON THAT IS.
EIGHT ZERO ITEM EIGHT A. B.
FOURTEEN THIRTEEN GLORIA.
LACKEY NO LACKEY NO RAMOS --
ITEM NINE AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY
GONZALEZ LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE FINAL VOTE ON THAT IS
[inaudible]
EIGHT ZERO THAT'S RIGHT
HI.
YEAH ONE OF THE HIGHER.
I HAVE A SET OF EIGHT A. B.
FOURTEEN THIRTEEN RAMOS
[inaudible]
RAMA SIDE.
FINAL VOTE ON THAT IS.
SIX TO TWO THIS IS -- AT THE
GARDEN.
THANK YOU FOR COMING BACK.
RELIVE THE CALL ON AB FIVE
SEVENTY ITEM NUMBER.
ONE CURRENT VOTE IS FOR TWO TWO
BURNER HORROR OF THAT
[inaudible]
THREE OF US.
THREE OF US I TO BILL IS OUT
[inaudible]
FIVE TO TWO YEAH CALL.
BRAD ON SITE AND TO AB SEVEN OH
SEVEN KALRA THREE OF US
[inaudible]
THREE OF US SIDE
SORRY.
WE'LL KEEP THE ROLE OF IN. FOR
ONE THIRTY MORE SECONDS. FOR
ALAN'S ITEM WHEN AB FIVE SEVENTY
AGUIAR-CURRY BRING HER BACK
[inaudible]
BOERNER HORVATH HI.
FINAL VOTE ON THAT IS.
SIXTY TWO AB SEVEN OH SEVEN
KALRA BURNER HER BATH BOERNER
HORVATH I A FINAL VOTE IS
[inaudible]
EIGHT ZERO EXCUSE ME
THAT'S IT [inaudible]
KEPT.
IF YOU CAN OF THIS BUT EDUCATION
ON THE FOR PROFIT [inaudible]
MEETING ADJOURNED